Hi Kean!
Hey Hendrik!
Willkommen bei Akonomisierbarer Folge
Oh mein Gott!
Was ist das?
Wir haben es geschafft!
Wir haben super lange drüber nachgedacht
über diesen Folgentitel
und zum Schluss kam raus
diese Nummer ist einfach die 42
Das bleibt auch dein Name gleich, oder?
Die 42
Die 42, ja. Haben wir uns irgendwas Besonderes ausgedacht
für diese Folge, sag mal?
Ja, ein bisschen besonderer als Folge 23
wollten wir werden, aber...
Ja, zum Schluss haben wir uns, glaube ich, einfach dafür
entschlossen, die Folge einfach aufzunehmen.
Ey, Folge 23 haben wir auch
aufgenommen.
Und, hast du schon die App?
Die App?
Ach, die App? Ich appe mit?
Nee, wie geht das? Ich appe jetzt.
Nee, ich appe mit.
Ich hashtag ich appe mit. Echt?
Heißt das so, ja?
Ja, es ist ein bisschen lächerlich, das Hashtag.
Aber die App habe ich installiert und finde sie auch sehr, sehr cool bisher.
Also macht er nicht viel.
Ist ja, wie meint ihr auf Twitter geschrieben haben,
quasi ein Mini-E-Book für Datenschutzbestimmung.
Und das war's.
Da ist eigentlich nichts drin.
Was mich ein bisschen schockiert hat, ich weiß nicht, wie es bei iOS ist,
aber musst du auch Location-Services anhaben?
Nee, nee.
Bei Android musst du Location-Services anhaben.
Aber das musst du ja, glaube ich, wenn du generell auf Bluetooth zugreifst,
auf Android, oder?
Nee.
Nee, eigentlich nicht. Also du musst Bluetooth und Location-based anhalten.
USB? Ach so, okay.
Ich meine doch, es wurde mir zumindest so von einem Kollegen erklärt, dass diese Exposure Notification-Geschichte, dass das irgendwie ein Unterteil von dieser Nearby-API oder Entitlement oder wie immer das heißt, vielleicht hängt das damit zusammen.
Ich weiß definitiv, dass ich, wenn ich auf Android diese FRITZ! Box, also diese AVM FRITZ! WLAN App benutze, um zu tracken, wie stark das WLAN hier gerade in der Umgebung ist, dann sagen die mir auch am Anfang, sorry, aber dafür musst du leider auch Location Services anmachen. Also irgendwas scheint Android da zu vermischen, was irgendwie nicht viel miteinander zu tun hat.
Das wurde, glaube ich, auch schon gut begründet
auf diversen Stellen, dass das halt eben so sein muss
und nicht anders geht aktuell.
Das wird seine Richtigkeit.
Ich bin mal gespannt, was als nächstes innerhalb dieser App so passiert,
ob sie da noch ein bisschen was verändern.
Ich habe am Anfang überlegt,
es wäre eigentlich lustig, diese App,
was hast du jetzt für ein Incentive, die ständig anzuhaben?
Die muss halt irgendwie an sein
und du musst dich jeden Tag selber daran erinnern,
dass du die auch anmachst, weil du hast ein Incentive, sie auszumachen,
weil sie braucht Strom.
Ach so, du machst die explizit aus?
Nein, aber du kannst da innen drin so ein Toggle machen,
wo du die ausmachst.
Und dann kannst du halt auch Bluetooth und Location wieder ausmachen.
Ach so, ja, nee, das ist mir zu umständlich.
Die bleibt einfach an.
Genau.
Ja, ich denke mir so, ach, wenn ich jetzt abends im Bett liege,
dann kann ich die wieder ausmachen.
Ja, aber ich meine, abends im Bett ist mir eh der Verbrauch egal,
weil da hängt die am Kabel dann.
Zumindest ist das mein Use Case.
Das macht nicht jeder so, klar.
Aber ich meine, man sieht die, das finde ich ganz witzig,
iOS zeigt ja die Batterie-Stats,
die Akku-Stats,
auch welche Apps so wie viel Strom verbrauchen.
Und in der anderen Weise wird das
COVID-19-Exposure-Logging hier
als Extrapunkt aufgeführt,
abseits von der App.
Also man sieht nicht den verbrauchten App,
der wahrscheinlich gleich null ist,
weil die App macht ja gar nichts im Hintergrund,
außer hin und wieder potenziell
eine Notification gepusht bekommen.
Und der ganze Rest läuft über die System-API.
Und der verbraucht aktuell bei mir
innerhalb der letzten zehn Tage,
kann ich einmal schauen,
was noch nicht ganz so ausschlagkräftig ist,
weil die Energia aktuell seit fünf Tagen erst läuft,
4% Akku steht hier.
Das geht, das geht.
Aber bei einem bekannten
Hallo Lars waren es schon 25%.
Also da wird es irgendwo ein bisschen schief gelaufen.
Aber ab und zu macht sie was.
Die muss sich ab und zu die Listen runterladen
und die vergleichen.
Ja, an sich, wenn da halt schon was drin stände.
Du kannst die Listen ja auch selber abrufen.
Ich packe das mal mit in die Show Notes.
Ich habe neulich gesehen, der Herr Schmidler
auch hat etwas
geantwortet auf irgendeinen
Priddlef-Tweet. Der Priddlef ist ja sehr aktiv
gerade, was diese App angeht.
Und hat er gefragt, und ob es schon
irgendwie überhaupt, ob sich überhaupt schon mal jemand gemeldet
hatte und dann hat er auf diesen Link verwiesen,
hier steht noch nichts dran. Das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich spannend.
Genau, also du kannst die
API von der Telekom, die auf
einer Subdomain auf t-online.de läuft, was ich ein bisschen
witzig finde, auch mal selber einfach curlen.
Das sind einfach die, unter Diagnosis-Keys
country.de, date,
kannst du die einfach alle abgreifen,
wohl anscheinend. Und da ist aktuell noch eine leere
Array, die da einfach kommt.
Es hat noch niemand, der die App installiert hat,
die sich gemeldet
als infiziert. Da hat er wohl bei
Tönnies niemand diese App installiert.
Kann gut sein.
Ich hatte zumindest überlegt,
naja, vielleicht gibt es ja Leute, die die ab und zu ausmachen,
um Strom zu sparen.
Und was kannst du dann als Incentive nehmen, um die Leute
dazu zu bringen, die App auch wirklich
immer anzulassen? Ich überlege, naja, man könnte
ja irgendwie so Punkte, achievements,
Du könntest das irgendwie Gamification-mäßig
versehen mit, du hast schon
so viele Kontakte getraced.
Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, nee, warte mal.
Bin ich getraced, infiziert.
Nee, warte mal, das ist eigentlich nicht gut, weil du willst ja nicht, dass die Leute
aktiv unbedingt rausgehen und andere Leute treffen.
Dann macht die Apple genau das Falsche.
Du hast so ein tägliches
Punkte-Budget
und Punktekonto und für jeden Kontakt,
den du siehst und für jeden Kontakt, den du erzeugst,
kriegst du Punkte abgezogen.
Und was du am Abend übrig hast,
kriegst du dann auf dein Dauerpunktekonto
drauf. Dann hast du quasi
ein Incentive, zu Hause zu bleiben,
oder was? Und am Ende kannst du dir das in
Payback-Punkten auszahlen lassen.
Wurstgutscheine
für Tennis.
Ah, witzig.
Ansonsten,
ich finde es gut, dass das Projekt anläuft. Ich finde es gut,
dass es mittlerweile schon über 10 Millionen Leute
hierzulande installiert haben.
Und ich finde es gut, dass das auch immer weiter
empfohlen wird an diversen Stellen, auch wenn sich da immer mehr
Leute darüber aufregen. Ich glaube,
der Dynamo Dresden hat
die App auf Facebook empfohlen.
Und da haben sich in den Kommentaren etliche
Fans wohl darüber aufgeregt, dass die
so die politische Scheiße rauslassen sollen.
Und das geht ja gar nicht.
Mindestens drei Ronnies waren
in den Kommentaren und haben sich beschwert.
Natürlich, das ist Dresden.
Ich kannte in meiner Zeit an der Uni
fünf Ronnies.
Ich will ja auch nicht sagen gegen Ronnies.
Günstigerweise auch fünf Kilians.
Uh, so viel. Ich kenne nicht mal fünf Kilians.
Naja, irgendwie kenne ich fünf Kilians.
Ist bei dir gerade das Licht ausgegangen?
Nee, ich hab bloß den dunklen Screenshot
nochmal aufgemacht von diesen Facebook-Kommentaren,
die geschickt wurden.
Da wirst du komplett schwarz.
Ja, also ich hab
eine Podcast-Empfehlung. Ich hab zum ersten Mal
jetzt
UKW gehört.
Kennst du UKW?
Das ist doch Radio.
Nee, irgendwie ist dir mal aufgefallen,
dass es schon seit Ewigkeiten keine neuen
CRE-Folgen
mehr gibt?
Stimmt, ja.
Das korreliert, glaube ich, ich habe den Übergang
wahrscheinlich nicht ganz mitbekommen.
Also jetzt werden uns vielleicht ein paar Leute in den Kommentaren schreiben,
das hat auch nichts miteinander zu tun,
aber es korreliert so ein bisschen.
Es gibt seit vielleicht einem Jahr,
ich habe jetzt mein Telefon nicht mal zur Hand,
um nachzugucken, gibt es UKW FM
und das ist der neue Labercast vom
Pridlove.
Und der hat in der mittlerweile vorletzten
Sendung von vor drei Tagen,
vor fünf Tagen,
hat er zwei Entwickler von
SAP interviewt, die an der App
mitgebaut haben. Zweieinhalb Stunden lang.
Das ist ja cool.
Und sie haben so darüber geredet, wie sie in das Projekt reingekommen
sind, wie das so war, diese API
zu bearbeiten oder dagegen zu entwickeln
und überhaupt wie der Ablauf der Entwicklung
von der App und wie die intern funktioniert und wie es
vielleicht weitergeht.
Durchaus empfehlenswert, packe ich mal in die Shownotes.
UKW
steht für unsere kleine Welt. Das ist ja witzig.
Das ist eigentlich ein geiles Akronym für so
einen Akronympodcast.
Ist gut akronomisierbar auf jeden Fall.
Auf jeden Fall.
Wenn ich dann akronomisierbar Punkte,
ne, viereinhalb von fünf Punkten,
würde ich dafür die Akronomisierbarkeit vergeben.
Tja, der Pridloff kennt sich halt aus
mit Akronomisierbarkeit.
Ja, CAE war auch schon sehr akronomisierbar.
Wir sollten mal wirklich so
einen akronomisierbaren Approval-Stempel
uns geben.
Ich glaube, wir setzen uns mal zusammen und entwickeln
neue Sticker.
Oh, neue Sticker, finde ich gut.
Gibt es sonst noch irgendwas
zu der App zu sagen?
Hm, wüsst grad nicht was.
Ich hab mal geguckt, ob es die für
iPad oder so für
Smartwatches oder sowas gäbe. Das wäre
vielleicht noch ganz cool, anstatt dass du die einfach bloß...
Kann mir aber kaum... Also zumindest
auf Darwin
Seite läuft das Exposure
Notification Framework aber glaube ich nur auf iOS
Devices. Also spezifisch
iOS, also nicht mal iPadOS,
was ja eigentlich bloß umgenanntes iOS ist.
Das ist so ein bisschen
schade. Aber
Ja, schon.
Vielleicht kommt das noch.
Also gerade für eine Uhr wäre es halt in der Hinsicht schon sinnvoller,
weil es ja noch ein Gerät ist, was man noch mehr mit sich rumträgt,
was ja mehr quasi noch zu der Person gehört.
Aber gleichzeitig weiß ich auch nicht, ob die Sendeleistung da...
Also ich meine, man will ja auch, das ist halbwegs einheitlich wahrscheinlich,
dass man quasi mit erkennen kann, was die Entfernung ungefähr ist,
die man da hinkriegt, dass man da zurückrechnen kann.
Ich weiß nicht, wie gut das mit der Uhr funktioniert
oder ob das dann ähnlich oder vergleichbar ist.
Gefährliches Halbwissen, ja.
Ja, ich habe zumindest mal wieder so ein Gespräch mit meinen Eltern geführt,
wo ich ihnen Technik erklärt habe, wo ich ihnen auch die App ein bisschen erklärt habe,
was da passiert und warum sie die ruhig installieren können,
ohne um ihre Privatsphäre sich Sorgen machen zu müssen.
Und hat meine Mutter so gemeint, auf Arbeit habe ich ehrlich gesagt mein Handy nie wirklich an mir,
sondern das lasse ich häufig dann einfach in einer Handtasche irgendwie in der Umkleide.
Und dann läuft sie den ganzen Tag ohne Handy rum.
das letzte Büro liegen
oder sowas, auch nicht unbedingt.
Das Konzept setzt voraus, du hast es halt immer an dir.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht,
aber so ein Fitbit,
das wäre ja noch gut, wenn das irgendwie
an so einem kleinen Gerät ist.
Dann hast du es ja wirklich immer an der Person.
Das ist mehr wirklich so ein Wearable.
Ein Kollege meinte auch wohl,
der wagt wohl, ich habe es nicht ganz verstanden,
ich kenne ihn jetzt auch nicht gut,
während der Pandemie, ich glaube,
war der in Milan
oder irgendwo in Italien
und die hatten da wohl in irgendeiner
Kirche oder so
kleine Bluetooth-Dinger, die du dir
anstecken kannst und die dann
grün oder rot leuchten. Und die haben halt wohl
rot aufgeleuchtet, wenn du jemandem zu nahe gekommen bist.
Also quasi Social Distancing
in Tech-Gadget-Form.
Bringt natürlich nichts für Exposure-Notifications,
also du kriegst nicht im Nachhinein mit,
wenn jemand, der in der Nähe war,
das sich infiziert hat. Aber das fand ich auch schon
ganz wichtig. Das ist eigentlich geil.
Das ist ja ein
Bluetooth LE
Beacon wahrscheinlich. Ich weiß nicht, wie gut
die Dinger, die werden ja für Indoor-Navigation
mitunter benutzt. Es gibt ja irgendwie,
es gab an der Uni bei uns die
ein oder andere Master- oder Diplomarbeit
zum Thema Indoor-Navigation mit
Bluetooth Low-Energy-Beacons.
Und
das ist eigentlich eine fette Idee. Baust du
einfach so ein Ding und dann kannst es
vielleicht, das kann man
einfach so Balk kaufen, du holst dir so ein Ding
und dann kannst du dann auf eine Demo gehen und kannst sagen,
hier, ich mach mir das Teil dran
und wenn du mir so nah kommst, wird's rot. Bei uns beiden.
Im Außenbereich
bringt das wahrscheinlich sogar was. Im Innenbereich
finde ich, ist das ganz irgendwie ein bisschen wieder Blödsinn,
weil, ich meine, man kann natürlich versuchen,
den Abstand einzuhalten und es ist auch sicherlich besser,
den Abstand einzuhalten, als nicht einzuhalten, aber
gerade in geschlossenen Räumen bringt's halt nicht
so viel. Da kannst
du auch gleich drauf verzichten, sobald du
mit mehreren Leuten im geschlossenen Raum bist,
haben sich eh alle Aerosole so gut
teilt, dass es kaum einen Unterschied macht, ob du den
Abstand einhältst oder nicht. Aber
im freien Bereich
würde es sogar tatsächlich wahrscheinlich recht sinnvoll sein.
Auf jeden Fall.
Was ist denn sonst noch so passiert?
Wir müssen noch direkt eine Maske haben, die die Rode aufleuchtet.
Das finde ich noch viel gut. Oh, da habe ich gestern tatsächlich
so einen Online-Shop gefunden. Die verkaufen irgendwie,
oh, die hatten so einen richtig geilen Namen.
Die verkaufen Masken?
Die heißen Lumen Couture.
Also quasi Lichtmode.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Couture wirklich Mode heißt,
aber kommt ja auf jeden Fall aus dem Fashion-Feld.
der Begriff.
Und die haben so
eine LED-Maske
mit, die halt so ein LED-Panel
vorne drauf hat. Da kannst du halt Text durchfließen
lassen. Also voll Daft-Punk-mäßig.
Super gut. Ja, ist schon geil.
Ich pack den Link mal mit in die Show-Notes. War leider ein bisschen
teuer, um es mir zu kaufen direkt.
Ich hab 130 Dollar
mit Versand, die man dafür hinlegen muss.
Holy shit. Aber ich fand's
schon echt schick. Ich hab von irgendwem so eine
Bastelanleitung, ich glaub
das war am Radio, ich hab's leider nicht direkt gesehen,
aber es gab von irgendwem so eine Bastelanleitung,
der sich
eine Maske mit so einem Mund-Display
gebastelt hat und wenn er geredet
hat, hat sich der Mund irgendwie bewegt
und da war dann auch irgendwie so ein
Sprachchip drin, der irgendwie
einigermaßen angenähert hat, was du mit dem Mund
machst oder sowas.
Okay, das ist herrliches Over-Engineering.
Auf jeden Fall, geil.
Richtig gut.
Ich hab jetzt mal wieder angefangen,
Starcraft zu spielen und zwar
das alte StarCraft,
das habe ich mir irgendwie für, das kostet ja,
weiß ich nicht, 10 Euro,
StarCraft Remastered gegönnt.
Das ist auch auf einem
modernen Bildschirm spielen kannst, ohne dass du dir
irgendwie die Pixel zählen kannst.
Und das ist aber auch immer noch so, die haben zwar
die ganzen Grafiken ausgetauscht, aber wenn du da am Anfang
dieses Mission Briefing hast, dann hast du halt irgendwelche
GIFs von redenden Mündern und
redenden Gesichtern, was überhaupt nicht zu dem
Audio, was da da abspielen, passt.
Und so ein bisschen stelle ich mir das vor,
dass du einfach bloß irgendwelche
random Lippenbewegungen siehst,
die sich dann dazu bewegen, was du
gerade sagst, und eigentlich nicht passen.
Ich freue mich schon, wenn wir alle in so einer
Ready Player One-ähnlichen
VR-Welt leben und dann
mit unseren Avataren da rumrennen und da halt
komplett irgendwie generierte Gesichter haben,
wo man dann auch sowas braucht für.
Aber dann halt wirklich quasi Leute mit wahrscheinlich
so einem Starcraft-Avatar rumrennen
werden, also zum größten Gesicht, nur weil
man es halt kann. Klar, ich würde die ganze Zeit
nur als Spider-Man rumlaufen.
Da brauchst du auch keinen Mund.
Das stimmt auch wieder.
Maximal noch so eine Kinnbewegung.
Naja, ich meine, das bist du jetzt mittlerweile die ganze Zeit gewöhnt,
wenn die ganze Zeit die Leute mit Maske rumlaufen.
Das ist echt wahr.
Ja.
So, ich probiere es nochmal. Was ist denn sonst noch so passiert?
Sonst noch so?
Hattest du letztens mitgekriegt,
dass da Leute
ins All unterwegs waren?
Das ist auf jeden Fall passiert.
Ja, ich hab mir, glaub ich, du redest von dem SpaceX-meets-NASA-Launch,
wo sie mit Crew Dragon zum ersten Mal Menschen transportiert haben.
Das war super cool.
Ich hab mir das, glaub ich, real-life angeguckt.
Ich war da grad auch bei der Familie.
Und dann haben wir hier auf dem Tablet draußen auf der Terrasse,
da hab ich gesagt, hier, mach mal an.
Und das war quasi der YouTube-Stream.
Da war's schon vorbei, dachte ich.
Und dann haben wir immer so ein bisschen,
da war grad diese Sequenz, wo sie an der ISS angedockt haben.
Ach so, also wirklich 14 Stunden später oder wann das schon war?
Das war, ja genau, wir haben am Vorabend das geguckt
und dann am nächsten Tag dann noch das andere.
Und da dachte ich, naja gut, okay, passiert jetzt lange nichts,
spulen wir mal vor.
Und dann haben wir es so langsam vorgespult.
Das hat ja echt ewig gedauert, wie du diesem Schiff zu gucken konntest,
wie es langsam auf die ISS zukommt.
Dann haben wir es so vorgespult, da wurde so ein bisschen langsam
dieses Schiff größer.
Und plötzlich konnten wir nicht mehr spulen,
weil da hatten wir einfach aufgeholt.
Und dann dachte ich, na gut, okay.
You've arrived at real time.
We're at now now, ist das Spaceball-Zitat.
Das ist so passend eigentlich, was dieser Film alles vorausgenommen hat.
Ja, dann haben wir es live noch ein bisschen geguckt.
Fand ich super geil.
Es ist ja dann ein bisschen durch die Nerd-Szene, durch die Nerd-Presse gegangen,
dass diese User-Interfaces, die sie verwendet haben, innerhalb von der, wie heißt das,
ist das wirklich Crew Dragon?
Ich dachte einfach nur innerhalb von dem Dragon.
Ich dachte, du hast die Kapsel für die mir alles durch.
Aber irgendwas hier ist Crew Dragon.
Gefährliches Halbwesen.
Zumindest die hatten da irgendwie kein
großes Raumschiff
oder Flugzeugartiges
Cockpit mit Knöppen
und die hatten glaube ich nicht mal einen Joystick
oder sowas. Die hatten wirklich gar nichts
manuell. Also die hatten schon ein paar
ein bisschen Interface, aber es wirkte auch
sehr danach, als ob die quasi Passagiere
sind in dem Remote Controlled
Dings da. Also die, also ich meine gut,
so viel anders war das
nicht als früher, aber
das ist immer noch, das ist ja so viel
Fly-by-Wire, dass du den Leuten einfach auch
nicht unbedingt
dann kannst du es auch gleich per Touchscreen machen
ich würde mich zwar vielleicht
ein bisschen mulmig fühlen in so einem Ding zu sitzen
und der Pilot zu sein
und nichts in der Hand zu haben
womit ich das Ding irgendwie grob steuern kann
aber naja
das ist ja wahrscheinlich eher Fallback, wenn alles andere schief geht
mehr machst du ja nicht
vielleicht kommt dann aus irgendeiner
Ritze von unten so extra
hochgefahren, so für den absoluten
letzten Notfall, so eine manuelle Steuerung,
aber die haben sie wahrscheinlich vergessen anzuschließen, weil sie
die nie gebraucht haben. So eine Klappe auf und dann fährt das
da so raus.
Ein Hologramm wird noch geleuchtet
von Elon als AI,
Cortana-mäßig dann. Oh Gott.
Ja, zumindest ging es so ein bisschen
durch die Nerd-Presse,
dass das ein User-Interface war, was
komplett auf Chromium basiert ist.
Ja, das fand ich auch sehr interessant.
Das heißt, der Screw-Dragon ist quasi eine Elektron-App.
Das ist schon ein bisschen hart.
Ich meine, mit JavaScript kann man ja so alles machen.
Aber anscheinend sogar
ins Weltall fliegen.
Aber es hieß, ich habe mich ehrlich gesagt
vergessen, weiter damit zu beschäftigen,
wo du das aufbringst. Ich habe überlegt,
es ist durchaus möglich, dass du einfach eine Anwendung baust,
die zwar
fünf Buttons per
Elektron anbietet, aber das muss ja trotzdem
mit gesamter Logik nicht in JavaScript
geschrieben sein. Ja klar, ich hoffe auch sehr, dass es nicht so ist.
Beziehungsweise, ich werde nicht sagen, dass ich das hoffe.
Im Prinzip kannst du wahrscheinlich auch
wirklich kritischere Software mit den passenden
Standards darin schreiben
oder schreiben, was immer du möchtest. Aber
ich gehe stark davon aus, dass das nicht
ein kompletter Electron-Stack ist, irgendwie
der alles dann wirft, inklusive die
Engines steuert. Das kann ich mir bei bestem Willen nicht
vorstellen. Nee, die Engines nicht, nee, das glaube ich nicht.
Aber die haben ja auch irgendwann mal geschrieben, dass sie ganz
vier C++-Entwickler suchen. Also da mache ich mir eher Sorgen
drum, als wenn sie es in JavaScript schreiben würden.
Bei Tesla, der ganze Kram ist ja anscheinend
wohl auch QT-basiert,
oder Qt-basiert, wie man in den Kommentaren
lesen konnte. Das wusste ich vorher auch nicht.
Ach so, krass. Das heißt, der Touchscreen
vom Tesla ist ein cute Dings.
Eine cute Anwendung.
Würde ich jetzt mal auf diesen Kommentaren
basierend davon ausgehen, ja.
Also die UI meint, im Auto
sei cute basiert. Ich muss zugeben, das finde ich
fast ein bisschen überraschender, als dass
das Cockpit von den Raumschiffen
mit Elektronen gemacht ist, äh,
mit Chrom gemacht ist.
Ich meine, vom Verhältnis her
ist ja,
ich lehne mich mal aus dem Fenster,
Aber ein Großteil der modernen Neuentwicklungen für Desktop
ist heutzutage schon,
also wenn es jetzt nicht direkt aus dem Hause Microsoft
oder aus dem Hause Apple kommt,
machen sehr viele hauptsächlich einfach eine Elektronanwendung.
Finde ich auch nicht mehr so verwerflich, wie ich es mal fand,
muss ich sagen.
Das ist immer eine Kostenfrage.
Und wenn du halt die Möglichkeiten hast,
oder die Möglichkeit suchst,
auf mehrere Plattformen gleichzeitig zu gehen
und da was möglichst Kohärentes zu bauen,
was überall sich ähnlich anfühlt und ausschaut
und sich auch bedient,
dann ist es wirklich bedeutend sinnvoller,
auf solche Technologien aufzubauen.
Und Elektron ist nicht per se scheiße oder langsam.
Man kann auch, ich meine, Siehe Slack,
das Ding war mal ein bisschen beschissener,
aber das läuft heutzutage echt erstaunlich performant
für das, was es tut.
Ja, VS Code ist ein super Beispiel dafür,
dass es gut funktioniert.
Also es ist eine App-Entwicklungsplattform.
Das VAP ist eine App-Entwicklungsplattform,
was extrem viele Sachen mitbringt.
Es bringt mittlerweile Bluetooth, USB
und VR mit.
Das Problem bei
Electron ist hauptsächlich, dass du einfach
Node mit ausliefest. Das ist manchmal
unsicher, weil Node unsicher ist.
Und du installierst
halt für jede Anwendung
das Ding von vorne, weil du es nicht als
gelinkte Library mit reinziehen kannst.
Du packest alles zusammen immer.
Obwohl ich mir für manche Sachen, wenn ich mir Riot
auf Arch-Lehnungs installiere, installiere ich mir
also Dependency ein extra Paket Electron.
Vielleicht kannst du es auch irgendwie machen.
Da ist immer mal so ein Gedanke, dass man vielleicht irgendwann
in der Zukunft Electron baut auf
Basis von Libservo, was natürlich
dann auch erstmal existieren müsste.
Und dann dementsprechend das vielleicht wieder alles
unter einen Hut bekommt, der ein bisschen
aufgeräumter ist. Da gibt es schon
Bastelprojekte. Mir fallen gerade die Namen nicht ein, aber das
ist schon ein paar Mal an mir vorbeigescrollt, dass da irgendwie
Leute sowas zusammenbauen. Ich glaube,
ich könnte mir fast vorstellen, dass Tauri
auch so eine Sache ist. Das hatte ich
in der letzten Folge erwähnt, aber ich glaube,
das könnte noch Webview-basierter sein.
Das ist ja eher das, was du möchtest,
WebView, dass du
den vom Betriebssystem mitgebrachten
Browser-Stack nimmst. Da bist du zwar irgendwie an das
festgenagelt, was der...
Oh, jetzt sind wir voll in diesem Thema drin.
Nee, ist doch
so ein Lieblingsthema von uns.
Prinzipiell gehe ich da auch mit, wenn du den WebView
vom System nutzt, also ich
kenne mich jetzt nur auf macOS damit aus,
dann hast du natürlich eine relativ kleine App,
wo du einfach nur dein Zeug mit reinwandelst,
deine Web-Anwendung. Ich meine, es gibt
auch die Leute, die gehen unter den Schritt weiter, das haben ja auch schon ein paar Mal
angesprochen, dass du halt wirklich bloß ein Webview hast
und das Zeug halt live von
deren Serverstypes, also wirklich mit der
Webseite interagierst. Und das finde ich schon wieder
ein bisschen eklig, weil da kannst du es auch sein lassen.
Binary, die nur noch sagt, starte ein Webview
und geh zu dieser URL.
Das ist quasi nichts, das ist einfach nur noch ein Icon,
was du da auslieferst.
Ein Icon mit einem Browser,
mit einem Minified-Browser.
Ja, das ist dann, und wenn du das, ja,
Minified, genau, und das kannst du dann auch noch weglassen,
dann hast du eine PWA.
Ey.
Ja, weil da muss ja trotzdem, also
da muss halt, aber die ist
dann ein Link, die einfach sagt,
das ist dann ein Link,
der wird erzeugt von deinem Firefox oder von
deinem Safari oder von deinem Chrome
und der sagt dann starte mich selbst.
Du könntest dann quasi deinen, das
geht bei Spotify, du kannst Spotify als
PWA, also das Progressive Web App
installieren und dann kannst du das, wenn du es aus
Firefox ausmachst, hast du ein Icon auf dem Desktop,
was Firefox startet. Ist es dann so,
wie wenn ich auf dem Mobility-Wert sage,
hier leg mal diese Webseite auf den Homescreen direkt.
Ja, ja, ja.
So ähnlich ist das dann gebaut.
Ja, ja, das ist nicht weit weg.
Also ich glaube, die größte, was PWAs hauptsächlich machen,
ist, dass sie irgendwie ein Manifest-Format spezifizieren.
Und einer defol definierten URL oder was?
Mit der URL und so ein bisschen Metadaten
und vielleicht noch ein paar Permissions,
was das Ding machen können möchte oder sowas.
Aber eigentlich können die alle nichts mehr
als eine Browser-Anwendung selber.
Und dann hast du halt schon lange,
Eigentlich hattest du das schon bei dem alten Mozilla.
Du hast irgendwie einen Command-Line-Flag an dem Browser selbst,
wo du sagst, lass mal die gesamte Browser-UI weg
und starte mal nur den Inhalt dieser Webseite.
Und dann geht genau das.
Ich meine, ich verstehe noch nicht ganz,
was eine PWA noch mehr kann.
Es gibt ja schon länger Webseiten,
die, wenn ich auf einem iOS-Gerät zum Beispiel bin,
dass ich mir Webseiten auf den Homes gelege,
was ich für manche Sachen gerne mal gemacht habe,
dass die halt dann durch irgendwelche passenden Parameter,
die sie auf der Seite hatten, hingelegt haben,
dass, wenn ich die dann öffne,
dass ich dann ein Chromeless Safari habe,
also ohne wirkliche UI drumherum.
Das dann wirklich sich anfühlt wie eine App.
Aber es ist da bleibt trotzdem die Webseite.
Ich interagiere immer noch, ich drücke da drauf,
es öffnet sich ein Safari ohne UI
und ich gehe auf die Webseite und kann dann damit interagieren.
Und habe einfach nur nicht die Adressleistung, die Toolbar unten.
Aber eine PWA kann doch, glaube ich, noch mehr als das, oder?
Da waren da noch irgendwie noch ein paar mehr Features.
Ich glaube nicht, dass die mehr kann,
weil sie nicht mehr APIs zur Verfügung hat, als sie im Browser hätte.
das Einzige, was das Betriebssystem halt macht
ist, dass es dir halt so
dass es dir das als
Icon installiert und das irgendwie
in deiner Application Liste mit auflistet oder so
und es für dich so tut, als wäre
das nicht, also es wird dann den Browser
wahrscheinlich in einem
leeren Profil starten, damit das
halt wirklich eine eigene Instanz von dem Browser
ist, kann ich mir vorstellen
und dann
startet quasi
dein Safari oder dein Firefox ohne
dein normales Benutzerprofil mit einem extra
Spotify-Profil zum Beispiel.
Und es wird dir aber, es wird quasi von dir versteckt,
dass das ein Browser ist.
Okay, also Desktop, Safari kann sowas nicht, soweit ich weiß,
aber müsste ich mal testen, wie sowas auf dem...
Also Desktop, Chrome und Firefox können das.
Okay, würde ich mir gerne mal anschauen.
Wie gesagt, das kannst du bei Spotify ausprobieren.
Wir haben das für unsere App,
haben wir das auch mal gebaut.
Wir haben es, glaube ich, nie geschippt, aber das ist durchaus möglich.
Auch das, was wir jetzt hier gerade
im Browser verwenden,
da hast du ja quasi schon alles, was du brauchst.
Genau, also
Chromium fliegt jetzt ins Weltall.
Stimmt, da haben wir angefangen.
Oh Mann.
Und es ist nicht abgestürzt.
Wie lange bleiben die da oben? Ein halbes Jahr?
Nicht abgestürzt.
Naja, sie müssen damit auch noch wieder landen.
Würde man davon ausgehen,
dass das Ding auch zurückkommen soll, ja.
Obwohl, ich muss sagen, so wie es momentan aussieht,
würde ich eigentlich
da oben bleiben wollen.
persönlich. Ja, es waren auch die besten Tweets
dazu. So, three people left the planet
today. Best choice.
Good timing. Auf jeden Fall.
Wollen wir
auf das andere Thema noch eingehen, was
quasi zeitgleich zu diesem
Raketenstart passiert ist,
was seitdem die Leute umtreibt?
Du meinst die
Demonstrationen und der damals
angehende Bürgerkrieg in den USA?
Gehst du da von dem Bürgerkrieg aus?
Also wie das angefangen hat,
das fühlte sich schon sehr
krass an. Aber prinzipiell,
ich würde sehr gerne das Thema
auf jeden Fall in der Folge noch kurz ansprechen,
zumindest. Ich werde auch
in die Show Notes noch einen Link packen, wenn ihr
die Möglichkeit habt, liebe Hörer,
könnt ihr gerne, von hier zu Lande kann man
nicht allzu viel daran teilnehmen, außer auch
eine Demonstration mit zu besuchen, die
hier stattfinden. Aber das sind meistens kleinere Sachen
natürlich als in den USA. Aber wir müssen uns natürlich
trotzdem bewusst sein, dass diese Probleme
ein weltweites Problem sind und
wir da auch irgendwie ein Teil
daran sind, gerade in unserer
Welt, in unserer
Tech-Welt, die ja auch sehr connected
ist, können wir doch ein bisschen
was machen und nicht zuletzt können wir auch einfach nur
Geld spenden. Wollen wir mal ganz kurz
erzählen,
welches Thema wir eigentlich
meinen, falls jemand diese Folge
2025 hört.
Okay, damals 2020,
als so alles passiert ist. Weißt du noch 2020,
dieses Scheißjahr? Nein, das wird nicht
das letzte bleiben.
Nee, wir reden gerade von der
größeren Black Lives Matter-Bewegung.
und allem, was
damit dranhängt.
Genau, was ist passiert in den USA
hat nicht zum ersten Mal,
sondern zum wiederholten Mal,
ich bin ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen
überrascht, dass dieser
Inzident jetzt was ausgelöst hat
oder dass es jetzt endlich geklappt hat, dass da irgendwie
was bewegt wurde,
dass vorher quasi regelmäßig
bereits ähnliche Sachen passiert sind. Was ist passiert?
Ein schwarzer Amerikaner
wurde auf der Straße von Polizisten
erst kontrolliert, dann
festgenommen oder festgehalten
und auf diese Art und Weise
oder im Vorgang
dieser Festnahme,
naja, grob gesagt,
ich will jetzt keine Termini
verwenden, aber umgebracht.
Ne, das war ein Mord.
Da brauchen wir nicht viel drum herum
brechen, das war ein deutlich Mord.
Und daraufhin gehen halt Leute auf die Straße
und ich habe,
seitdem hat man glaube ich jeden Tag
George Floyds Namen,
selbst in den deutschen Nachrichten immer noch,
weil immer noch am Anfang gesagt wird,
worauf das zurückzuführen ist.
Genau.
Ich finde es auch gut,
dass das Thema bisher noch nicht abgehebt ist.
Also klar, bei manchen Medien wird es definitiv weniger berichtet
schon darüber, aber die Leute sind nach wie vor
immer noch auf der Straße in extremen Zahlen.
Und das finde ich fantastisch,
dass da halt nicht aufgehört wird,
jetzt wo die Medien langsam aufhören, darüber zu berichten.
Genau, also in den USA sind sehr viele Proteste
ausgelöst worden dadurch.
Auch in
europäischen Ländern und weltweit gab es
Demonstrationen für
Black Lives Matter.
Aber was ich eigentlich spannend finde,
ist, dass dieses
allgemeine systematische
Rassismusproblem tatsächlich
thematisiert wurde, was wir ja als
sehr bequeme weiße Gesellschaft
doch irgendwie so ein bisschen unter den Tisch haben
fallen lassen oder unter den Teppich gekehrt haben.
Also dass quasi alles
alles rassistisch ist.
Wir sind alle ein bisschen rassistisch
und das ist eigentlich,
wir sollten uns das einfach
regelmäßig vor Augen führen und darauf achten,
wie wir mit anderen Leuten umgehen.
Genau das ist eben
der wichtige Punkt, den du da ansprichst.
Ob wir wollen oder nicht, wir haben alle irgendwo
diese Biases bei uns im Kopf.
Das ist auch ein,
ich will das jetzt nicht kleinreden, aber
das ist auch schon immer so ein
menschliches Ding, so ein In- und Out-Group
zu denken. Und wir müssen uns einfach bewusst sein,
dass wir das tun. Und wir müssen uns bewusst
dagegen versuchen anzukommen. Und irgendwo
wollen wir natürlich eine fortschrittliche
Zivilisation sein. Und dazu gehört es auch
einfach, möglichst inklusiv zu sein.
Und nur wenn wir wissen, dass wir
so denken und dass wir alle irgendwo
auch nur im kleinsten
Ausmaß
rassistisch handeln und denken,
wenn uns das bewusst ist und wir versuchen, dagegen anzukommen,
sind wir auf der richtigen Seite.
Genau, also deswegen wollte ich das hauptsächlich nochmal
betonen, also
was, glaube ich, in die falsche Richtung geht, ist, wenn dann
Leute schreien, ja, scheiß Nazis, weil
darum geht's nicht. Ja, dass die
rassistisch sind, ist allen klar,
aber was hauptsächlich
bewusst werden
muss, ist, dass eigentlich lauter
kleine Dinge das Problem sind, die wir
gar nicht merken. Lauter kleine Sachen,
die passieren,
wenn jemand irgendwo einkaufen
geht und negativ behandelt wird, oder
wenn jemand bei einem Jobinterview benachteiligt
wird oder wenn jemand aufgrund
seines Namens oder so ausgewählt wird.
Ich habe,
es läuft momentan als Kulturtipp,
läuft auf ZDF Neo,
kann man sich in der Mediathek angucken,
gibt es eine vierteilige Serie, die heißt
Deutscher.
Die, ich muss sagen,
sie ist eigentlich, ist der Inhalt
einigermaßen belanglos, aber ich finde es sehr gruselig, weil sie
vor dem Hintergrund spielt, dass
in Deutschland eine rechtspopulistische Partei
an die Macht gekommen ist nach einer Bundestagswahl.
Da kann man sich so richtig schon gruseln, wenn man sich das anguckt.
Es werden natürlich keine Parteinamen verwendet.
Heißt halt zufällig die Alternative für die Demokratie oder kurz AfD?
Nee, wie gesagt, es werden überhaupt keine Kürzel verwendet.
Das heißt immer bloß die bestehenden Parteien und plötzlich eine Partei, die rechts von der Mitte.
Pack ich mal in die Shownotes als Empfehlung.
Das ist unabhängig von diesem Thema.
Aber danach ist irgendwie auch in der Tech-Szene
so ein paar Themen hochgekommen,
die so aus dem Themenfeld dieser Rassismus-Diskussion herausgekommen sind.
Hast du davon ein paar mitbekommen?
Also das, was ich vor allem mitbekommen hatte,
war das, was auch hart diskutiert wurde.
Es geht um das Thema, den Master-Branch umzubenennen.
Und das war so ein bisschen zweischneidig, finde ich.
Also zum einen bin ich voll dafür und dieser Name ist schon immer beschissen und dieser Name kommt auch aus der Master-Slave-Beziehung, wo das Git die Benennung von CVS da übernommen hat, was die Benennung von Bitkeeper übernommen hat, wo es halt Master- und Slave-Repos gibt.
Also der Name ist auf jeden Fall mit der Konnotation da ins Leben gerufen worden und wird so benutzt.
Ich meine, klar, der fühlt sich sehr normal an und wir kennen diesen Master-Slave-Bezug heute sehr wenig, weil es nicht irgendwo im Git-Kontext den Slave-Namen gibt.
Deswegen fühlt sich
sich noch normaler an. Aber das ist meiner Meinung nach
auch gerade das Gefährliche daran, dass es halt
sich normal anfühlt. Und dieser Begriff sollte
möglicherweise nicht in dem Kontext normal sein.
Obwohl es ja auch Master
kontextuell, rein sprachlich,
gibt es ja auch Master,
ohne dass es ein Slave geben wird.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Es gibt auch den Master
und den Bachelorabschluss. Und das ist, finde ich,
der andere Kontext. Im Sinne von, du meisterst
etwas. Ich meine, es gibt auch
den Master von, also wirklich der Herr
oder der Chef von
ist, ohne dass
die gegenüberstehende Person wirklich
unbedingt ein Sklave sein muss.
Das ist alles wahr.
Das Beispiel, was mir jetzt einfällt, ist jetzt Master of Puppets
oder irgendwas Sinnloses.
Es gibt diesen
Begriff auch im anderen Kontext, ganz klar.
Und es gibt auch den Master-Copy-Begriff, den
viele versuchen dabei bei Git zu attributieren,
was auch legitim wäre. Meiner
Meinung nach trotzdem ist dieser Begriff
so oder so, abseits davon,
ob er da tragbar ist oder nicht, schon immer
nicht gut und
Warum muss man so lange darauf rumreiten,
diesen suboptimalen Begriff jetzt zu behalten?
Weil das ist ja so zu politisch korrekt
oder meinetwegen auch passende Argumente bringen.
Ist doch völlig egal.
Dieser Begriff ist nicht gut.
Warum kann man da nicht einen besseren Begriff nehmen,
so wie Main oder Stable oder Trunk?
Was ich letztens erst gemerkt habe,
nachdem es jemand auf Twitter angemerkt hat,
dass Trunk ja nicht entweder Rüssel von dem Elefanten war,
wo viele Leute...
Oder Kofferraum.
Ich hatte es als Kofferraum irgendwie und ich habe
nie ganz klar geworden, warum das
irgendwie, ja,
der Stamm und Branch ist
mind literally blown.
Aber es ist doch alles ein viel, viel besserer Begriff
als Master an der Stelle. Warum
nicht einfach diese kleine Änderung machen
und einfach fertig sein damit?
Dann ist das Thema vorbei.
Was ich in so einer Diskussion dann
immer ein bisschen blöd finde,
ist, dass dann Leute auf Twitter
anfangen, andere Leute zu shame
und sich irgendwie hervorheben, besser
weil die anderen es nicht machen.
Es gab so Leute, wie gesagt, das ist
normale Laziness, ohne jetzt
einen Vorwurf daraus zu machen. Es gibt Leute, die sagen,
ja, aber es ist schon ein ganz schöner
Zeitaufwand jetzt hier, überall die Masterbranches umzubenennen.
Und dann macht halt einer ein Video,
wo er zeigt, guck mal, wie schnell es geht,
deinen Masterbranch umzubenennen.
Also es hängt manchmal schon ein bisschen
mehr dabei. Ich habe es auch bei einem Projekt, wo ich es mit umbenannt
habe, gemerkt, gut,
da hängt noch eine CI mit dran und
ein paar Pages und ein paar andere Sachen. Also es ist nicht immer
ganz der schnellste Akt, aber
Wenn man es machen kann, und ich bin jetzt auch nicht durchgegangen,
hab das bei jedem meiner Repos auf GitHub gemacht,
aber bei denen, wo ich es jetzt in Zukunft sehen werde,
wo ich es schnell ändern kann, werde ich es auf jeden Fall mitmachen.
Einfach nur, weil mich diese Benendung schon immer gestört hat.
Aber ich hab mich da einfach an den Standard gehalten,
aber den nie in Frage gestellt, weil es halt der Standard ist.
Aber Git macht ja auch keine Annahmen darüber,
dass ein Branch damit Master existiert.
Das ist Git ja völlig egal.
Und ich meine, man könnte ja auch diskutieren,
dass bloß, weil man die Begriffe Master und Slave verwendet,
dass es ja nicht unbedingt heißt,
dass man das Konzept von Sklaverei gut findet.
Das ist einfach, man kann es ja auch,
das ist ja quasi ein sehr abstrakter Zusammenhang an dieser Stelle.
Ich werde auch niemanden verteufeln, der diese Begrifflichkeiten benutzt.
Aber wie ich schon meinte, es ist halt einfach nur,
wenn wir das mal weiter nutzen, diese Begrifflichkeiten auf die Art und Weise,
dann helfen wir es, diesen Begriffen immer mehr normal zu werden
und normalisiert zu werden.
Genauso wie mit Black-and-Whitelist.
Was ja, finde ich, ähnlich problematisch ist
davon, dass das White das Gute und Black
das Böse und das Schlechte das zu
Verbietende an der Stelle ist.
Aber abgesehen davon, White und Blacklist,
wie jemand, der die Begriffe nicht kennt, musst du das
erklären. Und Allow und Block oder Allow
und Denialist oder was auch immer, musst du es halt nicht erklären.
Das wird aus dem Namen her klarer. Warum ist das
nicht schon besser? Auf jeden Fall,
auf jeden Fall. Obwohl das eventuell auch im Amerikanischen
stärker konnotiert ist, Black und White,
dass man sofort an Hautfarben denkt.
Sicherlich.
Aber ja, also da stimme ich dir absolut zu.
Viele behaupten, ja, wir sind keine Rassisten, wir haben keine Hautfarben,
Problem, ich sehe keine Hautfarben, vor allem in Deutschland.
Das ist halt mangelndes Bewusstsein.
Deswegen stirbt auch niemand an den Grenzen hier.
Das ist halt mangelndes Bewusstsein. Also du hast das
schon immer und du musst dir ja dessen bewusst
sein, dass du unbewusst
auch ich
manchmal so, also ich meine, dass
sowas im Hinterkopf dann irgendwie
plötzlich aufploppt.
Das Wichtige ist, dass man sich dessen bewusst
macht und dann halt nicht danach handelt, sondern
darauf achtet.
Ein anderes Thema,
was noch rumgekommen ist, wo ich
hier einen Artikel verlinkt habe,
ist,
dass, es ist ja nicht nur
dieses Rassismusproblem
thematisiert worden, sondern auch Polizeigewalt
in den USA. Und es hat tatsächlich jemand
bei Rubocop ein Issue aufgemacht,
Rubocop umzubenennen.
Und der Threat zuckt
sich dann auch eine Weile hin, bis er dann
irgendwann von dem Maintainer
geschlossen wurde. Und der hat
dann hinterher irgendwie einen Tag später oder zwei Tage später
auch nochmal einen Blogpost darüber geschrieben,
dass er schon ganz schön unter Druck gesetzt wurde.
Einfach weil der Name Rubocop Leuten jetzt plötzlich gerade nicht mehr gefällt.
Und er ist auch ein bisschen enttäuscht gewesen,
dass plötzlich zwei Leute einfach das Projekt geforkt haben,
ohne sich mit dem Team abgestimmt zu haben.
Und das allein aufgrund des Namens Rubocop.
So, jetzt können wir sagen, naja, gut.
Das Konzept eines Polizisten.
Klar, Polizisten sind, wenn man sich so umguckt,
im größten Sinne meistens doof.
Aber so das Konzept ist ja jetzt nicht das gleiche wie das Master-Konzept.
Da stimme ich dir, glaube ich, auch zu.
Die Idee von den Polizisten ist ja, drauf zu schauen und to protect and serve.
Also das ist, wie du meinst, das Konzept.
Dass die meisten Polizisten, zumindest in den USA,
da irgendwie nicht in dieses Erwartungsbild reinpassen,
ist, glaube ich, ein anderes Thema.
Und wie gesagt, da ist es dann auch darauf hinausgelaufen,
dass er argumentiert hat, dass er den Namen beibehält.
Es gibt zwar noch ein weiteres Subprojekt,
was dann oben drauf baut, was jetzt RB Hint heißt
und eine freundlichere Oberfläche bieten soll.
Aber das Projekt wird nicht unbenannt, meinte er.
Okay, also ich würde mich da jetzt auch nicht querstellen.
Wir hatten immer ein ähnliches Thema ja damals,
ich weiß gar nicht, wann das war, mit dem Ruby-Projekt Factory Girl,
was Leute auch sehr schräg fanden,
dass das so sehr in Richtung eines Geschlechts gepusht wurde.
Und aus dem historischen Konzept heraus,
ich musste mich aber auch noch mal belesen,
wie es damals
angestrebt wurde mit der Umbenennung
und wie das dann passiert ist, aber das Projekt heißt ja seitdem auch
nicht mehr so.
Das heißt glaube ich seitdem
Factory Bot oder so,
aber ich bin an der Ruby-Welt nicht so aktiv,
also ich kriege das nur am Rande mit,
wenn das mal wirklich sehr populär werden sollte.
Was ist denn da die Konnotation? Ich weiß, da gibt es ein Lied.
Ah, das heißt das Factory Bot, ja.
Da gibt es einen Film.
Okay, das ist normal.
zu tun, wer
damals irgendwie
in
Factories tatsächlich
arbeiten musste oder so und
das ist ja auch nicht
geiles daran zu erinnern, aber
ich schneide das lieber raus.
Ja, also an dieser Stelle, wir müssen
jetzt auch nicht jedes Thema durchgehen.
Was jetzt gerade
auch nochmal als
Thema durch Twitter scrollt
zumindest, was ich gerade so mitbekomme, ist
Racial Bias in Machine Learning.
Ah ja.
nicht wiederholen. Die sind einfach nicht da.
Du kannst nur Informationen erzeugen, die
vielleicht auf dieselbe Art und Weise.
Du erzeugst ein Bild, was, wenn
es vor Pixels wieder genauso aussieht, wie das alte verwechselte Bild.
Genau, du erzeugst neue Informationen, die aber nicht unbedingt
die alte Informationen sein.
Du erzeugst die Informationen nicht aus dem Nichts,
denn du hast ein Trainingsset.
Ja, genau.
Und hier kommt jetzt
Racial Bias in Machine Learning ins Spiel,
denn Machine Learning Algorithmen
sagen immer, ja, das ist halt ein Computer.
Die sind nicht Bias.
Aber die sind genauso biased wie die Leute, die sie bauen.
Beziehungsweise wie die Leute,
das müssen die Leute ja nicht mehr mit Absicht machen.
Die Leute, die sie antrainieren.
Oder du suchst einfach, es gab auch mehr Beispiele,
wie diese Hin- und Herstellung von Man Hairdress,
wenn du googelst Man Hairdress Professional,
kriegst du Bilder von einem weißen mit einem professionellen Haarschnitt.
Und wenn du googlest,
man-hair-dress-unprofessional,
dann kriegst du Bilder von dem Schwarzen mit Redlocks.
Sowas passiert dann einfach.
Ja, super.
Und das ist einfach die Suche.
Also alle Daten, die du über Computer beziehen kannst,
sind bereits so gebiased,
dass es das widerspiegelt.
Wir hatten ja, ich glaube, das ist schon wieder locker zehn Jahre her,
wenn mich nicht alles täuscht.
Da habe ich auf jeden Fall noch nicht studiert gehabt,
als ich das Video gesehen habe.
Das war so ein Typ, der sich einen neuen HP-Laptop gekauft hat
und dieser Laptop hatte so eine Webcam-Software
mit Gesichtserkennung vorinstalliert.
Und die Gesichtserkennung hat, wenn sie ein Gesicht gesehen hat,
auf dich reingezoomt und dich im Bildausschnitt behalten.
Sprich, wenn du dich bewegt hast,
ist dir dieser Bildausschnitt quasi gefolgt,
also innerhalb des Field of Views, den ich Kamera eben hatte.
Und er selber war schwarz und hat sich erst mal ein bisschen erklärt
in der Webcam von wegen, dass diese Software das hat.
Und dann zieht er so von der Seite seine Kollegin ins Bild,
die weiß ist und plötzlich aus dem Nichts heraus
springt diese Software halt, wird diese Software
aktiv, die er gerade erklärt hat, und zoomt
halt auf ihr Gesicht rein und er ist halt völlig weggeschnitten
plötzlich. Und dann zeigt er so, dass
die Software halt sein Gesicht gar nicht erkennt, weil
die Gesichtserkennungssoftware, die da drauf lief,
das war noch nicht mal irgendwas ML-basiertes
zu der Zeit, das hat halt einfach
kein Konzept dafür gehabt, schwarze
Gesichter zu erkennen. Das wurde wahrscheinlich, also ich
vermute mal, ich kann das natürlich
hapäne unterstellen, aber dass die das einfach nicht getestet
haben, beziehungsweise das einfach nicht daran bedacht haben
an der Stelle, dass Leute auch anders aussehen
können. Vielleicht ist es auch an der Stelle,
wer weiß, keine Ahnung,
ein Kontrastproblem gewesen und
das ging gar nicht anders. Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es schwierig ist, für beide
gleich gut zu optimieren.
Aber so oder so ist es halt scheiße.
Ja, es ist kacke. Es ist genauso wie
irgendwelche Bildersuchalgorithmen,
die bei Gesichtern von
Schwarzen dann Bilder von Affen
vorgeschlagen haben. Das ist unglaublich
peinlich. Es gibt ja immer wieder, dass das aufkreuzt,
aber das ist so unglaublich peinlich.
Bei Google war das.
Ich erinnere mich noch an das, das war ein Google-Ding
vor, keine Ahnung, zwei, drei Jahren das letzte Mal,
dass ich das gesehen habe, aber sowas ist natürlich echt hochgradig
peinlich, weil das halt eine bekannte Beleidigung
noch ist. Ich glaube, wenn ich da in dem Team
gewesen wäre, was das entwickelt hat und ich
meine, wie gesagt, es kann dir
passieren, dass du über sowas, wenn
du zum Beispiel in einer Umgebung
lebst und arbeitest,
wo überhaupt keine schwarzen Menschen vorkommen,
dass du das vielleicht
auch einfach ausblendest oder sowas. Ich glaube,
wenn das passiert wäre bei der Demo, ich stelle
da so als Entwickler, würde ich sagen, okay,
I quit.
Ja, aber umso besser, wenn die Gesichtserkennung
nicht funktioniert für die ganzen Bilder
von den Demos, die sie da hatten, dann werden zumindest
die Leute mit dunkler Hautfarbe gar nicht erkannt und können
gar nicht angezeigt werden. Das ist jetzt das nächste
gruselige Thema. Das ist ja extrem,
viel passiert in der letzten Folge.
Das verlinken wir am besten auch nochmal
Last Week Tonight über Face Recognition.
Die war gut, die Folge.
Immer gut, die Serie eigentlich.
Genau, und da kommt noch dazu, dass diese
Facial Recognition-Geschichten auch bei Schwarzen
sehr häufig falsche Zuordnungen machen.
Das heißt, du läufst erst schwarz irgendwo da rum
und dann haben sie ein Foto von einem gesuchten Straftäter
und dann wirst du einfach fälschlich zugeordnet.
Was ja immer das Geilste auch daran ist,
mal völlig abseits von dem Thema zur Gesichtserkennung,
dass wir Software haben, die versucht,
aufgrund von Low-Resolution-Dingern Gesichter zu erkennen
und mit Leuten zu verlinken.
Und dass das halt oftmals dann für wahre Münze genommen wird
und einfach, ja, das ist die Person.
Und dann passieren da automatisch schon andere Prozesse,
darauf losgetreten.
Selbst wenn ein Mensch drauf schaut, ist das nicht
vertrauenswürdig. Im schlimmsten Fall werden
dann Polizisten losgeschickt, die dann nicht mal
das Bild zum
Danebenhalten
zur Hand haben, um es selber zu verrichten.
Im schlimmsten Fall kommen dann Polizisten wie bei
Breonna Taylor, die treten deine Tür ein und schießen
sie achtmal, während sie schläft daheim,
während sie in ihrem Haus schläft und
schießen achtmal auf sie und sie ist tot.
Also
2020, da ist
noch Luft nach oben. Es gab irgendwie Kalender,
Da stand dann irgendwie da, dass dann im Juni Meteoriten einschlagen,
im September der Yellowstone-Nationalpark-Vulkan ausbricht im Oktober.
Hast du das mitgekriegt, dass die tatsächlich mehrere Beben in Yellowstone gemessen haben?
Das wäre ja wirklich das grüne Abschluss für das Jahr.
Also das ist ja jetzt nicht irgendwie einfach nur komplett ausgedacht,
sondern da waren tatsächlich mehrere Beben im Yellowstone.
Da, wo ein fucking Super-Vulcano ist, der, wenn er losgeht,
wahrscheinlich das Leben auf diesem Planeten, so wie wir es kennen,
komplett beenden würde.
Das ist nicht nur einfach.
Wie gesagt, so wie es sich 2020 momentan entwickelt,
mich würde es echt nicht wundern.
Was ist denn da los?
Da muss man ja wirklich fast an irgendeine höhere Instanz
wie Gott glauben, dass da irgendwo das gestört wird.
Das kann ja nicht sein.
Kennst du die herrliche Seite ist 2020over.com?
Nee.
Ich packe die mal mit in die Show Notes.
Da hat einfach jemand eine schöne Auflistung gemacht
mit Stichpunkten pro Monat.
Was passiert denn?
Ich hatte schon ganz vergessen, dass die
Feuer in Australien auch noch dieses Jahr waren.
Gefühlt sind die schon fünf Jahre her.
Und das Schönste an der Seite ist eigentlich,
dass die kommenden Monate auch schon Punkte haben,
unterschiedliche Anzahlen von Stichpunkten,
aber die halt noch ausgeschwärzt sind.
Als ob da die Person schon genau weiß,
was da passiert. Aber ich verrate es euch erst, wenn es kommt.
Ich kann an dieser Stelle
noch einen Kulturtipp in die Liste schmeißen.
Kennst du Julie Norky?
Das ist so eine YouTuberin,
die macht Sketche.
Das ist so ein bisschen wie
ein bisschen wie diese Sketche, die manchmal auf Z1 liefen.
Irgendwie blonde Frau
macht Sketche.
Super gutes Zeugs. Und das erste, was ich von der nicht gesehen habe,
ich bin bloß auf die Aufmerksamkeit geworden, da gab es ein Video
von
vor zwei Monaten, also
April.
Explaining the Pandemic to my
Past Self. Es fängt so an, Februar,
wie sie am Tisch sitzt und dann plötzlich macht es plopp,
dann sitzt ihr gegenüber sie selbst aus
April und dann
das kann ich sehr gut empfehlen.
Und da gab es dann irgendwie nochmal zwei Monate später
gab es dann eine Fortsetzung von,
wo die aus der Zukunft, quasi die aus April,
gerade wieder im April angekommen sind,
dann sitzt ja plötzlich die aus Juni gegenüber.
Ganz, ganz, ganz großartig.
Ich schmeiße es hier immer in die Liste.
Ich hatte es auch schon mal vertwittert.
Vielleicht kennen es auch die Leute schon,
aber ich schmeiße es einfach mal drauf.
Klingt auf jeden Fall sehr witzig.
Ja, also wenn 2020 damit endet,
dass irgendwie ein Supervulkan ausbricht
und die Menschheit auslöscht,
ein bisschen verstehen.
Verstehen?
Also von Rechtfertigen dem Vulkan gegenüber?
Ist dir aufgefallen,
wie alle sich über 2016 aufgeregt haben?
Weil es auch das Jahr war, in dem Trump gewählt wurde.
Und in dem Jahr,
das war auch schon so ein Jahr, wo alle gesagt haben,
2016 ist so ein richtiges Kackjahr.
Und in dem Jahr sind auch...
In dem Jahr sind auch ganz viele
zum Beispiel irgendwelche Promis gestorben.
Das war 2016, das ist ein beschissene Jahr.
Ja. Und ich glaube,
ganzen Promis, die da gestorben sind.
Ich hab mir gedacht, naja, die haben einfach,
das war ein guter Zeitpunkt.
Die haben den Scheiß 2020 nicht mehr mitbekommen.
Die haben zwar dummerweise teilweise noch mitbekommen, dass
Trump gewählt wurde,
aber der ganze Mist, der danach gekommen ist, also es ging hauptsächlich
um Amerikaner, aber den ganzen Mist
danach, den haben sie dann nicht mehr mitbekommen.
Aber na gut.
Wollen wir wieder
zu was Technischem übergehen, Kilian, komm.
Jo, was ist denn noch so passiert?
Hast du das ganze Debakel um die
Plattform hey.com mitbekommen.
Ich habe gesehen, das ist irgendwie ein Projekt von
DHH oder aus dem,
wie heißt die Company?
Basecamp machen die.
Aus dem Basecamp-Lager.
Und das ist ein
Debakel. Also ich habe, mir ist es als erstes
aufgefallen, weil es irgendwie bei Hacker News stand,
unter hey, User Interface ist completely
HTML-based.
Genau, also die hat technisch ein bisschen was Cooles gemacht,
dass die HTML over the wire machen.
Dass die quasi alles im Backend
rendern und dir dann schicken.
Das finde ich recht witzig,
technisch gesehen.
Wie ich das verstanden habe, das allererste Ajax
funktioniert, dass du irgendwie irgendwelche
HTML-Tags dann
gerendert bekommst. Ich hatte es eigentlich als
Improvement verstanden, dass du
nur noch die Daten und nicht mehr
das Anfangs- und das End-Text zweimal
jedes Mal geschickt bekommst.
Aber das war 2013, dass ich
das gedacht habe und seitdem ist es so viel passiert.
Wir sind jetzt full circle zurückgekommen.
Wir machen jetzt so viel kleinzeitig, dass es schon wieder
ist und wollen jetzt wieder gar nichts kleinseitig machen.
Und Hey hat gesagt, wir wollen jetzt
E-Mail neu erfinden. Wir machen jetzt
mal mitten aus dem Nichts einen E-Mail-Service
und der heißt hey.com.
Genau, die haben für ein bisschen viel Geld sich
die Domain hey.com geholt und
wollten ein Love Letter
in Anführungsstrichen an E-Mail damit
machen und E-Mail für die Leute,
die E-Mail überdrüssig geworden sind,
neu erfinden. Also einfach
quasi ein bisschen schicker mit neuen
Features E-Mail so machen, dass es wieder Spaß
macht. Und das kann ich auch ein bisschen
vollziehen, weil ich sehe mich selbst als Person,
die mir echt leid ist und es am liebsten
abschaffen möchte. Und ich habe mir diese
Feature-Previews angeschaut.
Ich habe es jetzt nicht geklickt.
Man hat mir gedacht, an und für sich,
vieles davon klingt sehr sinnvoll.
So auf den ersten Blick.
Genau, auf den ersten Blick finde ich sowas auch nicht
verkehrt, wenn man da versucht, noch ein bisschen mehr oben drüber zu machen.
Es gibt eine ganze Reihe Clients, die so ein Snooze-Feature
zum Beispiel auch mit haben. War ich persönlich
nie ein Freund davon, weil
das natürlich nicht sauber clientübergreifend
funktioniert. Und ich zum Beispiel
auf meinen Plattformen meistens den, also ich bin
nur auf iOS und macOS eigentlich unterwegs und
da nutze ich jeweils die Mail-App, die Apple
gebaut hat und wenn ich auf einer von den beiden Plattformen
das austausche durch einen anderen Client, wie
ich auch keine Beispiele nenne, die so Custom
Features haben, dann passt das nicht gut zu der anderen
Plattform. Genau und meistens
wird das dann darüber gemacht, dass das irgendwie so eine gesnuzte
Mail zum Beispiel einfach in einen anderen iMap-Ordner
schiebt und dann halt der Client laufen
muss und regelmäßig schaut und das dann einfach zurückzieht.
Und das finde ich technisch ein bisschen
unsauber, aber klar, es läuft auf den
Möglichkeiten, die ein E-Mail bietet. Das Backend
gibt es halt nicht anders her.
Genau. Es ist auch völlig legitim an der Stelle,
das so zu machen. Ich will auch nicht auf dem Feature rumhaten.
Es ist bloß kein Feature, das ich persönlich
angenehm finde in der Nutzung. Deswegen habe ich
mich persönlich damit nie angefreundet. Aber wenn das bei anderen
Leuten gut funktioniert, prima.
Wie hieß denn dieser E-Mail-basierte
Instant-Messenger-Dings?
Ich gebe gerade noch Delta Chat.
Delta Chat, ja genau.
Das war auch so eine Geschichte.
Es gibt viele Sachen, die auf E-Mail aufmachen.
Die haben es über den Ordner gemacht.
Ja, genau. Im Prinzip ist es ja auch nicht verkehrt, Dinge auf E-Mail aufzubauen.
E-Mail ist ein sehr gut bekanntes Protokoll.
Und das Beste an E-Mails ist, jeder hat E-Mail.
Es gibt kaum eine Person, die online unterwegs ist, ohne eine E-Mail-Adresse.
Und E-Mail ist halt überall.
Und das ist halt wirklich toll.
Und ich mag das sehr.
Und das Protokoll an sich ist ein bisschen kompliziert,
wenn du da selber dringend drauf aufbauen möchtest, finde ich.
Aber man kann es nutzen.
Und es werden auch Dinge drauf aufgebaut.
Du hast vor allem immer noch mehrere Protokolle für eins für Senden und eins für Empfang.
Genau. Und verschiedene für Empfang, die unterschiedlich laufen.
und ja, es kommt aus einer anderen Zeit noch,
müsste man sagen.
Und es ist auch nicht verkehrt,
dass das halt nicht von heutigen Techniken verhunzt ist.
Keine Ahnung.
Solange es noch geht.
Bis Google demnächst mal irgendwann sagt,
dass Gmail jetzt nur noch innerhalb von Gmail
ein geschlossenes Ecosystem wird.
Und dann ist Gmail halt komplett gekapselt.
Hat er nicht, gab es nicht so eine Alliance von E-Mail-Anbietern,
die irgendwie Darkmail oder irgend so was bauen wollten,
was komplett sicher ist,
wo der Typ von Lava-Bit und noch ein paar andere mit drinstecken,
um irgendwie wirklich endgültig...
Irgendwas gab's da, ja.
Ja, das ist nie passiert, oder?
Ich glaub's nicht.
Ich glaub, du kannst auch nicht genug Momentum zusammenkriegen,
um E-Mail zu revolutionieren.
Du kannst maximal einen Nachfolger schaffen,
der komplett eigenständig und inkompatibel damit ist.
Aber ich mein, das machen wir ja mit HM.
Und es gibt schon seit Jahrzehnten
gibt es immer wieder diesen einen Post auf HM,
auf Hiker-News alle paar Monate von wegen,
hier, ich hab E-Mail neu gebaut.
Schaut euch das mal an, so ein Show-Hein-Post.
Genau, und so einen haben wir jetzt gerade wieder und der nennt sich
hey.com?
Naja, so halb. Also die Kommentare sind dann meist immer so was,
hey, you just reinvented IM.
Aber mit hey.com
ist es halt so ein bisschen halb in die Richtung.
Also zum einen finde ich es cool, dass die
Dinge auf E-Mail aufbauen, haben wir ja gerade schon gesagt.
Aber zum anderen haben die halt ein sehr
weirdes Ecosystem und
die zwingen Nutzer
dazu, ihre Clients nutzen zu müssen,
weil sie halt keine IMAP-Schnittstelle
anbieten. Gibt's einfach nicht. Kannst du nicht drauf zugreifen.
Also die haben ein E-Mails, du kannst da E-Mails hinschicken und das kann für dich E-Mails schicken, aber was du damit machst, ist quasi nicht mehr E-Mail.
Genau, es ist quasi kein E-Mail. Also es ist E-Mail-kompatibles IM, habe ich das jetzt betitelt, so für mich.
Und das finde ich halt, also dadurch, dass du sprichst halt mit dem Service von Hay.com kein IMAP zum Empfang, sondern du sprichst halt über deren HTML-Schnittstelle da, die die da gebaut haben.
Und deswegen kannst du auch nur deren Clients benutzen und du bist an deren Clients gebunden.
Das ist wahrscheinlich eine große Rails-Anwendung,
wenn es von Basecamp...
100 Pro.
Ja, eben.
Wenn es von DHH kommt,
dann muss es ja Rails sein.
Das ist ja gar nicht alles möglich.
Bzw. die Firma heißt, glaube ich,
hier heißt die immer noch 37 Signals
oder heißt die mittlerweile Basecamp?
Da bin ich mir gar nicht sicher.
Ist eigentlich auch egal.
Jedenfalls haben die das eben gemacht.
Und das finde ich auf der einen Seite nicht ganz so geil
und auf der anderen Seite,
was ich nicht ganz so geil finde,
ist der Preis.
Ich habe kein Problem damit,
für den Service zu bezahlen
und ich habe auch kein Problem damit an sich,
was die veranschlagen mit den 99 Dollar pro Jahr.
für was bezahlen, wenn das gut ist
und ich darauf aufbauen,
dass ich das brauche und das überall benutze,
dann finde ich das einen völlig angemessenen Preis.
Was ich lächerlich finde allerdings,
sind diese Vanity-E-Mail-Adressen mit Sonderpreisen,
die die haben. Wenn du bei denen eine zwei- oder eine
dreistellige Adresse haben möchtest,
dann buchst du den.
Genau, also du kriegst immer eine
hey.com-Adresse und wenn du eine
drei-Buchstaben at hey.com
haben möchtest, zahlst du plötzlich 350
zwei Buchstabenadresse haben möchtest, zahlst du
999 Dollar im Jahr.
Und deren Begründung ist, because we can.
Und das finde ich
hochgradig lächerlich. Ich meine, klar können
die das machen. Jedem ist es frei,
sein Business so zu gestalten,
wie sie möchten. Aber ich finde das einfach nur
nutzerfeindlich auf der einen Seite.
Das ist einfach
nicht, das wirkt wie Shakedown.
Und zwar genau das, worauf wir an einer Stelle
zu sprechen kommen. Weißt du noch, als wir
mal im ASCII saßen und uns irgendwie lustige
Top-Level-Domains angeguckt haben und die haben alle so
25 Euro gekostet und dann war
mal einer dabei, die 50 Euro gekostet hat.
Da geht es irgendwie Kaffee und Coffee
und Bar und
Sexy und Rocks
und dann gab es Rich
und das hat einfach mal 1000 Dollar gekostet
anstatt 25.
Das ist ja Signaling.
Es ist alles Signaling.
Du kannst mit einer kurzen
Vanity-Adresse darauf zeigen, ha ha, schau mal, ich bin reich.
Und genau darum geht es ja.
Aber ich finde den Preis
einfach hochgradig unangemessen.
1000 Dollar im Jahr für eine nicht mal ganz E-Mail-Adresse zu verlangen, finde ich, daneben.
Aber wie gesagt, können die ja machen, wenn sie wollen.
Die sind völlig freigestellt.
Ich würde dann schnell noch einen anderen Dienst nehmen und dann URL, also hier Weiterleitung noch davor schalten,
damit ich dann irgendwie meine eigene Domain haben kann oder sowas.
Ich meine, jeder kann sich seine eigene Domain kaufen und zahlt einen Bruchteil davon.
Genau.
Kannst du ja auch eine.rich-Domain kaufen und Hendrik-is.rich kaufen und dann hey-at-Hendrik-is-rich.com.
haben. Ich kann auch
die Nick von Rich
verklagen und sagen, mein Nachname
ist Rich. Ich will
gefälligst. Ja, ich weiß nicht,
ob die Klage durchgeht.
Aber ich finde das ein bisschen lächerlich.
Aber das ist ja immer noch nicht
das Debakel gewesen an der Stelle.
Das Debakel, was die hatten, war, dass die
eine App, also dadurch,
dass sie ihre Kunden ja an ihre Apps binden,
brauchen die halt auch Apps auf der einen Plattform.
Unter anderem auch iOS, was sicherlich eine recht
große Plattform für die mit ist. Ach ja, das war das
Genau, und Apple hat halt die App, ich glaube, in der ersten Version zugelassen und mit der zweiten Version wieder rausgenommen, weil Apple meinte, das entspricht halt nicht den aktuellen App Store Guidelines, weil du startest die App und ohne Account kannst du da halt nicht weitermachen.
Du musst dich anloggen und du kannst dich nicht registrieren in der App, weil du dann dementsprechend auch zahlen müsstest für einen neuen Account.
Und Apple möchte das halt, wenn du keine sogenannte Reader-App bist, die für die Sonderregeln an der Stelle gelten, musst du über In-App-Purchases von Apple gehen und dann musst du Apple 30 Prozent davon abdrücken.
Und wenn die 1000 Dollar von einem Kunden wollen, kann ich sehr viel gut verstehen, dass sie nicht 30 Prozent davon an Apple abtreten wollen.
Generell 30 Prozent von allem.
und das ist nicht wenig Geld.
Das 30%-Modell von Apple ist auch schon
manchmal ein bisschen fragwürdig, oder?
Ja, ich habe letztens
erfahren, dass die 30% tatsächlich
so ein bisschen der Industry Standard sind.
Wenn du mal gerade in der Spielebranche über
die diversen Plattformen gehst, das sind überall
30%. Also das ist gar nicht so untypisch.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie es bei
Google ist im Play Store.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es da Sonderregeln gibt. Apple hat ja auch
ein paar Sonderregeln für große Firmen, was ich absolut fragwürdig
finde. Also große Firmen zahlen
oftmals nur 15%.
Aber dieses 30 Prozent finde ich auch absolut maßlos und übertrieben.
Da können wir auch gleich nochmal drauf zu sprechen kommen.
Aber ich sehe auch absolut ein, dass Hey das nicht möchte.
Und Apple sagt halt, nö, ihr müsst das aber machen.
Ihr müsst das bezahlen, sonst kommt eure App nicht in den Store.
Weil ihr seid halt keine App für die Sonderrechte gelten.
Ihr seid keine Reader-App, in Anführungsstrichen.
Deswegen habt ihr keine andere Wahl.
Ihr müsst das machen, Punkt.
Und die App darf nicht in den Store, ohne das zu tun.
Und da weigert sich Hey aber, das zu tun.
DHH spricht halt öffentlich von
mafiösen Taktiken von Apple.
Seine Rhetorik ist ein bisschen arg fragwürdig
an der Stelle. Und dass das halt ein Shakedown ist,
was ich besonders lächerlich finde, gerade in dem Kontext,
dass er halt, was die
für Summen von ihren Nutzern verlangen.
Es gibt diese Webseite, die er dann irgendwann gepostet
hatte, die heißt ausgesprochen
oder auch wirklich ausgeschrieben
You download the app and it doesn't work.com
So eine Liste
von, wo
sie mal sagen, hier
Hey wurde abgelehnt, weil also es sind Apps,
ähm
zumindest hast du hier eine Liste von
das steht hier oben drüber, zumindest hast du hier eine Liste von
Apps, ob sie angenommen wurden
von Apple oder nicht
die oberste ist hey, das wurde abgelehnt
und dann kommt aber Netflix
wurde bezahlt, damit es überhaupt
funktioniert, da steht nämlich auf dem Startbildschirm
trying to join Netflix
you can't sign up for
Netflix in the app, you know
it's a hassle, we know it's a hassle
after you're a member
you can start watching in the App.
Das ist auch so eine Apple-Regel, du darfst
auch nicht auf dem Bildschirm Leute zu
deinem externen Registrierungsprozess schicken,
sondern du darfst
halt nur sehr vage ansprechen.
Das ist auch ein bisschen sehr weird.
Das ist schon strange. Dann als nächstes hast du GitHub,
die App funktioniert auch nicht, ohne dass du, na gut, du musst ja
nichts zahlen, aber
funktioniert auch nicht, ohne dass du
ein Konto hast. Dann Google Docs,
Fastmail und dann
gerade Fastmail ist halt interessant,
weil Fastmail genau in dieselbe Richtung wie
geht. Es ist halt wahrscheinlich
Apple damals nicht aufgefallen beim Review,
dass Fastmail auch exakt auf dieselbe
Art und Weise dagegen
verstößt, gegen diese Regel. Fastmail ist halt auch
eine E-Mail-App. Es ist halt offenes E-Mail.
Also du kannst es, also Fastmail, ich hoste
nur der E-Mail. Genau, es ist wirklich
E-Mail, E-Mail. Ich bin auch froh, glücklicher Fastmail-Kunde.
Also ich hoste meine E-Mail über Fastmail
schon seit vielen Jahren mittlerweile und finde
das auch wirklich toll. Aber
die App musst du nicht nutzen,
unterladen für Fastmail. Du kannst halt,
weil es halt E-Mail ist, auch einfach andere
Mail-Clients nutzen. Aber es hat halt genau das selbe
Problem. Du lädst die App runter und du brauchst
halt ein Fast-Mehr-Konto und du musst dich mit dem einloggen.
Und wenn du kein Fast-Mehr-Konto hast, dann kannst
du nichts tun. Du musst auf die Seite gehen
und dir vorher ein bezahltes Konto klicken.
Und erst dann kannst du dich dort einloggen.
Und wirklich gesagt, dasselbe Ding eigentlich
an dem Hey gescheitert ist.
Und ich meine, ich will Apple echt nicht
verteidigen. Und ich hatte auf Twitter schon was
leicht Widersprüchliches, nicht Widersprüchliches,
was ich mittlerweile ein bisschen anders sehe,
gepostet, dass ich Hey an der Stelle
nicht, also das Problem
an der Stelle nicht einsehe, weil ich zu der Zeit der
Meinung war, dass
ich nicht möchte, dass Apps eigene
Bezahlstrategien haben können, weil
man ja dann Apps hat, jede zweite App, die
dann plötzlich will, dass du deine Kreditkarteninformation
einträgst. Und ich finde das aktuell sehr angenehm,
dass wenn ich ein Abo abschließe in der App,
oder generell auch nur einen Single-In-App-Purchase
mache, dass das alles über meine App-Lite
abgerechnet wird. Das ist halt Convenience für dich, aber
damit sind halt die,
es ist halt Apple, genau das, es sind die
übelsten Gatekeeper für die gesamte
Absolut. Für die gesamte Industrie.
Ich sehe auch, es ist mittlerweile ein bisschen anders,
dass Apple halt wirklich dadurch es schafft,
dass Apps halt mehr Friction dem Nutzer gegenüber haben
und sich schlechter verhalten im Großen und Ganzen,
als sie es tun Menschen auf der Plattform.
Es gab ja auch genügend Beispiele,
in denen Apple irgendwie eine App unterdrückt hat,
weil sie schon in der Schublade eine eigene Alternative hatten.
Dann haben sie irgendwas, was bereits existiert hat,
dann durch ein eigenes Produkt gekillt.
So Sherlockings passieren ja immer wieder.
Und das passiert ja wirklich,
dass Apple eigene Services rausbringt,
die die existierende Business-Modelle kaputt machen.
Und das würde ich Apple nicht vorwerfen,
aber die haben, glaube ich, noch nie,
also zumindest kenne ich gerade kein Beispiel,
wo sie jemandem das vorher schon in den Riegel vorgeschoben haben.
Oder auch im Nachhinein.
Also, ja, ich habe gar kein Beispiel parat.
Also explizit für den Fall,
dass Apple halt dann eine eigene Sparte aufgemacht hat
oder schon aufgemacht hatte
und dann im Vor- oder im Nachhinein gesagt hat,
nee, das darfst du nicht mehr, wir können das besser.
Das kommt mir gerade ein bisschen komisch vor.
Ja, dass du das nicht mehr darfst,
da haben sie, glaube ich,
fällt mir jetzt auch kein Beispiel ein.
Aber es gibt ja so oder so,
ist Apples Review-Prozess natürlich nicht einheitlich.
Und der ist arg flawed.
Ich hatte bisher das Glück,
dass ich noch nie dagegen gelaufen bin.
Bisher die einzige App von mir,
die jemals abgelehnt wurde,
war ein iMessage-Sticker-Pack
mit Gesichtern von mir selber als Sticker.
Da haben sie gesagt,
die darf nicht in den Store,
weil ich nicht signifikant genug bin.
Fand ich ein bisschen traurig.
Deswegen machen wir jetzt diesen Podcast gerne.
Genau, ich muss einfach bekannter werden.
und dann kann ich diese App irgendwann nochmal pushen.
Das Killian-Sticker-Pack.
Aber ansonsten hatte ich bisher Glück,
aber viele andere Leute haben halt immer wieder Probleme
und das Review-Team macht halt auch viel Scheiß.
Die machen mal random Entscheidungen,
wo du einfach dieselbe App nochmal submittest
und dann geht's plötzlich.
Oder es geht nicht mehr einfach derselbe Bild,
der auf dieselbe Art und Weise funktioniert.
Oder Leute hatten Probleme generell mit In-Air-Purchases,
wo das Review-Team gesagt hat,
die In-Air-Purchase geht aber nicht.
Und dann hast du den Bild nochmal submitt,
weil die haben alles getestet lokal
und die Docs nochmal gelesen
und alles genauso gemacht, wie man es machen kann,
nochmal hochgeladen. Geht immer noch nicht.
Nochmal hochgeladen. Geht immer noch nicht. Nochmal hochgeladen. Ah, es geht.
Und es war einfach exakt derselbe Bild immer wieder.
Und wahrscheinlich ist das Review-Team einfach selber
an irgendwelchen Problematiken im Prinzip
System gescheitert, ohne es zu merken.
Und das ist halt lächerlich. Oder andere Leute scheitern daran,
dass das Review-Team, das finde ich das Beste,
dass das Review-Team sagt, das geht nicht, deine App widerspricht
gegen die Guideline, schickt dir Screenshots von deiner App,
aber es ist nicht deine App, sondern eine andere App.
Ja, das sind halt auch Spansions.
Ja, klar, natürlich
machen die auch Fehler, aber das ist
kein einheitlicher Prozess und dieser Prozess ist schon
immer scheiße und kaputt und
die machen halt auch schon immer
Fehlentscheidungen und du musst halt dagegen
ankämpfen und das ist halt, das ist
kacke, das sehe ich absolut ein.
Da habe ich jetzt auch
kein Aber mehr, das ist kacke.
Da fällt mir die Geschichte ein, weil du gesagt hast,
die Leute haben einfach das gleiche immer wieder
eingereicht und dann
wurde es irgendwann angenommen. Also das ist ja
ein Verfahren, das auch in anderen
Branchen so gang und gäbe ist.
Ich weiß, das ist ein
von uns beiden bei der
Übergabe seiner Doktor,
also nach seiner erfolgreichen
Verteidigung seiner Doktorarbeit
auch noch so einen Preis bekommen hat
für, was war
denn das?
Triple Redundant
Submissions oder sowas
in der Akademie,
also in Akademia, weil er einfach
Papers einfach unter unterschiedlichen Namen
immer mal wieder eingereicht hat,
wenn man das mal durchbekommen hat.
Und ähnliche Geschichte gibt es auch von
Fools Garden. Kennst du Fools Garden?
Das sind die mit
Lemon Tree, dieser Song.
Genau, und die
hießen aber gar nicht ursprünglich Fools Garden.
Die hießen, die hatten
25 andere Namen, weil sie dieses Lied
bei unterschiedlichen Studios immer wieder
unter anderen Bandnamen eingereicht haben.
Irgendwann wurde das angenommen und haben sich gedacht,
ach scheiße, dann heißen wir jetzt halt Fools Garden.
So kann man es auch machen.
Krass.
So, aber jetzt davon abgesehen, dass die sich irgendwie mit Apple
und deren Bezahlmodell überworfen haben.
Also Apple ist so ein bisschen fishy,
weil die Gatekeeper sind und selber entscheiden,
was sie durchgehen lassen wollen und was nicht.
Und weil sie inkonsistent sind.
Und Hey hat sich jetzt nur darüber aufgeregt,
dass sie eine App haben, wo du bezahlen musst.
Und das nicht durchgegangen ist.
Aber was ist jetzt das eigentliche größere Problem bei Hey?
Das größere Problem ist,
dass sie ihre App nicht in den Store bekommen
und Apple ihnen aktuell ihr Business kaputt macht.
Das ist das Debakel, um das es geht.
Hey, weigert sich, das anzupassen und die 30 Prozent an Apple abzudrücken,
was ich verstehen kann.
Und Apple weigert sich, haben sie sogar öffentlich gesagt,
Statements gepublished, das anders zu machen an der Stelle.
Also ich kann das nur mit dem Gedanken,
dass ich das halt auch nicht nachvollziehen,
dass das Apple...
Also es gibt zwei Gründe, warum Apple das macht.
Es gibt diesen ganz großen Grund von wegen,
Apple verdient da sehr gut daran, 30 Prozent zu nehmen.
Und das sind gigantische Beträge, die der Apple zugute fließen.
Und ich kann sehr gut verstehen,
dass man das nicht einfach einstreichen möchte als Firma.
Logisch.
Ich meine, das ist viel Geld, was da kommt.
Und auf der anderen Seite kann Apple halt auch argumentieren,
dass sie halt versuchen, den Endnutzer zu schützen.
Und so ein bisschen sehe ich das auch ein.
Das war auch das, was ich auf Twitter geschrieben hatte.
Wenn meine Mom mich, das macht sie häufiger,
mich anruft und sagt, da ist gerade auf meinem Handy eine App gewesen,
die hat gesagt, ich zahle jetzt Geld für.
Was zahle ich da jetzt schon dafür?
Hast du da ganz explizit dieses Pop-up gesehen,
von wegen du zahlst jetzt dafür
und hast deinen Daumen auf den Sensor gelegt?
Nein.
Oh, dann zahlst du auch nicht dafür.
Und das ist halt sehr angenehm zu wissen,
dass es halt diesen Sicherheitsfaktor da gibt
und dass man auch nachschauen kann,
wo die Abos da sind.
Ja, aber ich meine, wenn der mal nicht aufpasst
und dann plötzlich, okay,
drückst einfach mit deinem Daumen auf den einen Button
auf deinem Telefon gehst,
dann hast du plötzlich über den App Store bezahlt.
Das ist schon ein bisschen scheiße.
Ja, aber du kannst es...
Fliegt gerade was rum.
Ja, aber du kannst es sehr einfach wieder canceln,
weil die halt alle durch den App Store laufen
und im App Store hast du eine Auflistung all deiner Abo-Zahlungen.
Und du kriegst von Apple auch noch mal eine E-Mail,
die der Provider halt potenziell dir nicht geschickt hätte.
Und du kannst halt auch sehr einfach das canceln.
Und was ich halt sehr gut finde,
ist, der Service kriegt gar nicht deine Bezahldaten.
Und dass das Bezahldaten nicht sicher gestort werden
und immer wieder verloren werden, wissen wir ja.
Ja, gut, okay, dass ich natürlich nicht meine Kreditkarte
oder sowas weitergeben möchte oder sowas.
Das ist klar.
Deswegen gibt es auch sowas wie PayPal.
Ja, hat auch wieder Probleme.
Alles ist halt irgendwo kacke.
Aber so ist es zumindest an der einen Stelle zusammengeführt und ich kann das besser als Kunde managen. Also ich sehe es, ich hätte für mich, ich habe ja auch kein Business an der Stelle, wo ich Milliarden versuche zu verdienen, wo ich dann 30% Apple abdrücken müsste.
Aber an der Stelle sehe ich das mehr ein,
dass das auch praktisch für die Kunden ist.
Aber gleichzeitig, ich verstehe es auch absolut,
dass das Kacke ist und zu schlechteren Apps auf der Plattform führt.
Und ich meine, es ist Kacke einfach, dass die Kindle-App,
ich nutze sehr gern die Kindle-App auf meinem iPad.
Mein iPad ist quasi einfach nur ein fancy Kindle,
auf dem ich Bücher lese.
Und ich kaufe die sehr gern bei Amazon,
einfach nur, weil es super bequem ist für mich.
Und ich kann die in der Kindle-App aber nicht kaufen,
weil Apple das Amazon verbietet,
weil Amazon 30 Prozent der digitalen Einkäufe an Apple abtreten müsste.
Das wollen die natürlich nicht. Deswegen kann ich keine Bücher
aus der Kindle-App kaufen und muss die über die Webseite
kaufen und dann werden sie in der Kindle-App runtergeladen.
Und das führt halt einfach dazu, dass ich
eine schlechtere App habe auf der Plattform,
weil Apple diese Bestimmung da drin hat.
Und das ist halt auch Kacke.
Natürlich hätten wir, wenn mit Apple das lockern würde,
Spam-Apps, die, ich meine, es gibt aktuell
solche Ausmalbücher-Apps,
die nach drei Tagen Trial
dir 50 Dollar die Woche berechnen wollen.
Diese Apps existieren einfach nur,
um Leute abzuzocken, die dann darauf reinfallen
und dieses Abo abschließen. Und die hätten wir
wahrscheinlich noch effizienter,
wenn wir die Möglichkeit haben, diesen Apps
direkt Kreditkartendetails zu geben.
Aber vermutlich hätten wir mehr
bessere Apps als
ein Übermaß an Beschissenen, glaube ich
einfach mal, wenn Apple das anders machen würde.
Auf der anderen Seite kann man natürlich auch einfach...
Du musst ja bloß mal den App-Store von
Apple und den Play-Store von Google
nebeneinander halten, dass da für Rauschen besteht.
Ja, ich meine, beide haben
eine unglaubliche Menge an Bullshit. Ich habe mal geguckt,
es gibt immer noch den Kindle Paperwhite,
weil ich überlege, eigentlich müsstest du doch auf so
Papier-Display lesen auf so einem E-Ink-Display,
oder? Anstatt auf einem iPad.
Ich finde das Kindle auch ein angenehmes Gerät,
aber mein iPad finde ich angenehmer,
weil ich mache darauf offensichtlich nicht
viel mehr als Bücher lesen und ein bisschen
im Web zu surfen und PDFs anzuschauen, aber
alles, was auch nur einen Hauch über Buchlesen
hinausgeht, macht das iPad halt tausendmal
besser als Kindle.
Wir hatten mal so ein Angebot
von der Firma, dass wir uns
irgendwie, dass wir irgendwie
ein Kindle und dann irgendwie so und so viele
Fachbücher von der Firma
bekommen könnten auf dem Kindle.
Und
das habe ich dann, haben wir auch so
ein bisschen untereinander überlegt und haben überschaut,
ein Fachbuch auf dem Kindle lesen, ich meine,
du hast ja da ein geforstes Layout, du hast vielleicht
Grafiken, du hast vielleicht bei uns
Quelltext drin und dann brauchst du schon Farbe
und ein bisschen höhere Auflösung,
deswegen ist das nicht so geil. Ich hatte mal ein Kindle,
so einen von den allerersten, als
die noch fünf Buttons unten und
überhaupt kein Touch-Display hatten, der war der
allergeilste. Danach hatte ich mal von meinem Vater
so ein Touch-Kindle in der Hand gehabt.
Du kannst den Daumen
nicht mehr, oder den Finger
nicht mehr auf den Text legen.
Auf dem Display halten konntest damals.
Ich hätte auch, dass das eins der ersten, wo du halt,
also nicht mehr das weiße erste, sondern das danach, aber wo du immer noch
eine Tastatur unten hattest, eine Hardware-Tastatur.
Genau. So ein graues,
was auch aussah wie Star Trek
Next Generation, so ein bisschen.
Das konntest du noch ein bisschen hacken, dann kannst du,
gab es irgendwie eine Anleitung, wie du dann
über SSH draufkommst und dann
Bildschirmschunderbilder einrichtest oder sowas.
Ich glaube, ich hätte auch so ein Paperwhite
rumfliegen und wollte es mal an die Wand hängen.
Einfach nur als so ein Startausmonitor, wo
Busabfahrten und Wetter drauf
hängen. Weil das ist ja das Schöne an dem E-Ink-Display.
Es ist quasi einfach nur noch ein E-Ink-Display.
Weil es ja wirklich kaum noch drumherum
irgendwie Buttons hat.
Ja, und was ist jetzt
BuyFYI?
Achso, das ist einfach so eine witzige Antwort auf
hey.com.
Buy.fyi.
It's 2020 and we need to talk about
E-Mail. Fuck it.
Buy is the first E-Mail service to
automatically respond with an insult and then
delete every E-Mail sent to you.
Das ist einfach eine kleine Verarsche von hey.com.
Du kannst tatsächlich
da auch eine E-Mail kaufen. Ich weiß
nicht, ob du dann am Ende wirklich eine Alias bekommst oder so.
Ich wollte no reply at buy.
Das war schon unten drin, das gab es schon.
Ach so.
Das war, glaube ich, irgendwo aufgelistet.
Ich konnte es noch kaufen.
Ja? Aber meine Kreditkarte
hat es nicht angekommen.
Questions need help, email us at
no reply at buy.mv.
Das steht ganz unten.
Dann hat es einfach nichts validiert.
Wahrscheinlich kriege ich auch keine Adresse.
Aber wenn du dich durch die Form durchklickst, kannst du einfach
einen Geldbetrag auswählen und der wird dann
gespendet an Black Girls Code.
Und das fand ich toll, wollte das machen.
Aber meine Kreditkarte nimmt es nicht an.
Und ich weiß nicht wieso.
Aber ich finde die WD witzig.
Das ist eine coole.
Da ist unten steht ein Counter.
932 E-Mails avoided.
33. Cool, da kannst du immer mal...
Das ist auch schön, diese Tweets, die sie unten
stehen haben, so als Recommendations und
einer meinte, ich habe mich
angemeldet und musste denen nur meine Gmail-Login-Daten
schicken und habe dann gemerkt,
ich konnte mich bei meinem PayPal nicht mehr anmelden, habe
die angefragt und der Support meinte, das hat seine
Richtigkeit, das ist der Demigrationsprozess.
Finde ich schön.
Okay, also E-Mail ist
endgültig tot.
Nein, E-Mail ist toll und lebendig
und E-Mail soll nicht sterben. E-Mail ist das einzig
erfolgreiche, dezentrale Protokolle, was wir haben.
Und egal, was Moxie auf dem Kongress erzählt,
von wegen E-Mail ist eh nur Gmail, das stimmt nicht.
Ja, aber dann könnten wir wirklich mal ein neues E-Mail-Protokoll,
da wäre es nice, wenn dann müsste dann so ein Player wie,
wir haben eine globale Katastrophe
und Google und Apple müssen sich zusammentun,
um jetzt das Protokoll von E-Mail endlich mal zu modernisieren.
Ja, was willst du denn modernisieren?
Wenn es dir wirklich nur um das Kleinprotokoll geht,
da gibt es schon Möglichkeiten,
FastMate hat er unter anderem, ich glaube, mitentwickelt oder
selbstentwickelt. Etwas, das nennt sich
JMAP, das ist quasi IMAP over JSON.
Das ist
eine Möglichkeit, das zu modernisieren.
Das finde ich auch ganz schick.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob der FastMate-Client sogar direkt JMAP
spricht. Kann sein, aber sie schaffen halt
IMAP deswegen nicht ab, sondern
es ist halt zusätzlich eine Sache, die du haben kannst.
Ja, aber das können
dann wieder nicht zwangsläufig alle Clients.
Natürlich nicht. Das kann quasi
gar kein Client aktuell. Aber ich meine,
irgendwo muss man anfangen. Und wie gesagt, sie schaffen
anderes ab dafür. Sie versuchen
bloß, moderne Sachen ins Spiel
zu kriegen damit.
Stimmt auf jeden Fall.
So.
Genau, ansonsten können wir ja bei Matrix
weiter pushen, bis das alle haben und dann
schaffen wir E-Mail ab und machen E-Mail über Matrix.
E-Mail ist ja auch nichts anderes als
eine längere Nachricht.
Mal gucken.
HTML möglicherweise formatierte.
Bei Matrix fehlen mir noch so ein paar Funktionalitäten
und ich habe den Eindruck, dass wir, wenn wir
Matrix dann jetzt weiter pushen, dann haben wir
irgendwie 20 Jahre später nochmal XMPP
neu erfunden, bloß dass es nicht mehr auf
XML, sondern
auf REST basiert,
was mittlerweile auch schon nicht mehr so wirklich aktuell
ist. Ne, also Matrix macht
schon ein paar Dinge ein bisschen anders.
Grundlegend ist es schon sehr ähnlich, das stimmt schon.
Aber gut, es ist halt auch IM.
Aber Matrix will auch an sich mehr
sein als IM. Matrix ist ja
eigentlich nichts anderes als eine
eventually consistent JSON-Database,
die halt zufälligerweise ganz praktisch ist.
Es ist nicht wirklich Instant Messaging, also gerade
Bei manchen muss ich...
Genau, es ist mehr
eigentlich wirklich bloß eine
eventually consistent database, wo du halt
Blobs zusammenschickst, die gemerged werden und dann
diese Chain wieder rausgesinkt
wird. Auf jeden Fall. Hast du mal
Matrix, das haben wir auch regelmäßig
in den Folgen, hast du mal dieses
wirkliche Peer-to-Peer-Matrix ausprobiert?
Das Peer-to-Peer-Matrix
habe ich bisher bloß mal in der Demo von gesehen, aber noch nicht
selber ausprobiert, nee. Wie bist du da
erreichbar? Über was?
Das ist halt die Frage. Da hatten wir
letztens auch, glaube ich, eine Unterhaltung im Akkommunisierbar-Channel,
wenn ich mich nicht täusche, wie man das genau
auch skalieren kann.
Da war ja die Debatte, wenn du tausend Leute,
die alle P2P
nutzen, die also quasi ihren
eigenen Homeserver direkt an ihrem Client hängen haben,
wie man sowas hinkriegt,
dass die halt sauber verteilt werden, die Nachrichten
zwischen tausend Teilnehmern und keine Ahnung.
Achso, wenn du eine Mailbox hast,
äh Quatsch, wenn du einen Channel hast quasi.
Genau, tausend Leute
in einem Channel und jeder ist ein
Peer-to-Peer-Client. Also jeder hat
seinen eigenen Homeserver. Ja, deswegen.
Und der Homeserver läuft auf deinem möglicherweise Mobilgerät
und muss halt mit allen anderen
reden und Nachrichten quasi an alle anderen schicken.
Du hast vor allem dann mehrere
Homeserver selber, weil
du hast eins auf deinem Telefon und eins auf deinem Tablet
und eins auf deinem Laptop. Potenziell,
klar. Ja, deswegen denke ich, dass das nicht
unbedingt skaliert. Es wäre cool, wenn sowas
entweder von irgendeinem lokalen, was weiß ich,
deinem lokalen Chapter vom CCC betrieben wird
oder wenn es auf deiner Fritzbox läuft oder auch so.
Ich finde es auch, ja, ich finde es auch
sinnvoller, das nicht auf dem Client
laufen zu haben, beziehungsweise oder nur
auf dem Client laufen zu haben, wenn
es wirklich auch,
also die aktuelle Form von Matrix ist ja
sehr Homeserver zentral, also
dein Account, dein Matrix-ID hängt
an deinem Homeserver und
die ist nicht, also multiple Accounts
auf verschiedenen Homeservern haben nichts miteinander zu tun.
Die können nicht synchronisieren,
die können nicht aufeinander verweisen, da ist halt aktuell gar nichts.
Es ist geplant, dass du auch
Aliasser auf anderen Homeservern anlegen kannst,
die auch dann quasi Daten
Aber so wie es aktuell ist, wenn du dann quasi den Homesurfer an deinem Gerät hängen hast, also in dieser Peer-to-Peer-Form und dein Client wegwirfst, dann ist da auch alles mit verschwunden.
Und mir gefällt es mehr, wenn der Client halt wirklich ephemeral ist an der Stelle und ich den Client in den Teich werfen kann, mein Handy, und keine Daten verloren gehen.
wirklich Peer-to-Peer aus dem Client raus zu machen,
das kannst du als Proof-Konzept
nehmen oder als für bestimmte
Use-Cases, wo du mit jemandem
kommunizieren willst, ohne dass du wirklich traceable
bist oder sowas. Es gab ja mal
diesen Tor-Netzwerk
basierten
Chat-Client, der hat man auch mal
erwähnt. Dafür aber so
wirklich pragmatisch ist es auch nicht unbedingt.
Ja, oder wenn halt Daten
synchronisiert werden zwischen den einzelnen
Clients, sauber auf irgendeine
geschickter Art und Weise. Genau, wenn du sagen kannst, das Ding ist
komplett eigenständig, aber es
sorgt halt mit diesem anderen Ding dafür, dass
beiden jetzt, und du musst ja bloß wissen, wer war als
letztes Mal online, dann hat der halt gewonnen und
dann ist die Synchronisation vielleicht relativ einfach
oder so. Genau, also sowas existiert halt
aktuell nicht, aber mit sowas könnte man
halt das dann schicker machen.
Cool.
So, haben wir Matrix für diese Folge jetzt auch mal
kurz besprochen. Was gibt's
denn sonst noch? Ich hab gesehen,
es gibt jetzt irgendwie so einen Bookmarking-Service
das für Social-Media-Geschichten, das heißt irgendwie Lada-IO,
es kostet aber Geld, hast du dir das mal angeguckt?
Ich habe es mal kurz reingeschaut,
aber ich zahle schon für mein persönliches Hosted Dev0
bei Pinboard.in, wo ich Dinge reinschmeiße und nie wieder anschaue.
Da brauche ich nicht noch ein Dev0 für.
Ach ja, Lada ist, sorry, nicht Social Media,
das ist Bookmarking for Developers,
wo du irgendwie GitHub-Repos sortieren und taggen kannst.
Und das macht Pinboard eben auch und dafür bezahlst du bereits Geld?
Ja, Pinboard ist generell so, wenn du Delicious noch kennst,
eher so ein Klon davon, einfach quasi Bookmarking mit ganz vielen Tags.
Und wenn du dafür Geld bezahlst, dann wird auch zu dem Zeitpunkt des Bookmarkings
noch ein Snapshot der Seite gespeichert, den du dir später nochmal anschauen kannst,
wenn die Seite nicht mehr existiert oder wenn du einfach nur zu diesem Zeitpunkt das haben willst.
Quasi das, was Archive.org auch macht.
Und da hängen halt schon, boah, da müssen wir mal reinschauen.
Ich glaube, der hat sogar stehen in den Settings,
der Entwickler, wie viel Speicherplatz der für dich schon veranschlagt.
Ach, aktuell nur ein paar Gigabyte, das ist ja gar nichts.
Du hast ein paar Gigabyte bei denen.
Genau.
Aber ich weiß von ein paar anderen, die das auch nutzen,
die halt da schon...
Kannst du mal kein Screensharing bei mir antworten?
Ich dachte, du zeigst mir das mal.
Aber gut, okay.
Dann sind das aber zwei grundlegend andere Sachen.
Das eine ist, wenn ich jetzt mir Lada
IO angucke,
dann ist das ja quasi sowas wie
Astral-App.
Ist das nur auf GitHub bezogen oder was?
Nicht
unbedingt, aber
ich meine,
es ist quasi
hier als Beispiele
sind jetzt hier erstmal nur GitHub-Repos
verlinkt.
Lada ist bookmarking for things
on the web you'll need again.
It's perfect for curating lists of libraries,
tools and reference materials.
So es geht für GitHub Stack Overflow.
Ja, das war's.
Und du kannst es mit
einem Bookmarklet aus dem Browser
raus machen.
Ich würde es glaube ich auch nicht
machen. Ich habe ein bisschen
mit Astral App rumgespielt,
weil ich mittlerweile tatsächlich den Überblick
über meine GitHub Stars verloren habe und das wäre
schon schöner, wenn ich die irgendwie besser
sortieren und irgendwie nachträglich nochmal
angucken könnte. Wo ich die
Stars ja eher als Likes und
nicht als Bookmarks
vergebe. Ja, ich hab
da auch jegliche Kontrolle drüber verloren.
Ich find's immer wieder geil, wenn man irgendwann
irgendwas Cooles geschickt bekommt oder
sonst wo findet auf Twitter oder vielleicht
in der GitHub
Timeline auf der Homepage sieht.
Oh, das klingt ja super cool.
Super cooles Projekt, unbedingt merken
es raus so hoch und steht auf dem Button
plötzlich Anstar. Hä?
Also hast du doch echt ein nächstes Star.
Und was ich manchmal mache, ist, dass ich das dann
unstare und dann sofort wieder stare.
Haben wir wieder hoch zu pushen.
Damit, genau,
damit es nochmal in der timeline auflauft.
Der Screenshot ist hier aber von Dezember
2016. Ja, also gut. Ich weiß auch
bloß, dass es irgendwie an mir vorbeigestrollt ist,
weil es irgendwie auf Hacker News
diese Frage stand, mit würdest du dafür bezahlen?
Und mittlerweile habe ich aber den Hacker News Artikel
dazu gar nicht mehr. Ich benutze
immer noch sehr gerne Pocket.
Echt? Okay.
Ich komme jetzt euch in den Zürich einfach nicht klar.
Für mich ist das wirklich bloß eine Müllhalde.
Ich dampfe da wieder Dinge drauf und habe
die Absicht, da reinzuschauen. So auch in meiner
Pinboard-Cue, weil du hast ja auch
auf Pinboard auch die Möglichkeit, Dinge als unread
zu markieren. Und
ich lege da echt viel rein, aber
ich weiß, dass ich da nie wieder
reinschaue. Das ist wirklich Dev Null quasi.
Na gut, okay, aber warum
bezahlst du dann dafür?
Weil ich es mag, Dinge da reinzulegen.
Also wenn ich das nicht habe, diesen Ort, wo ich Dinge rein
dumpen kann, dann ist meine
Tab-Leiste noch länger.
Und das geht einfach nicht.
Also ich mache das tatsächlich bei Pocket so,
du hast es einfach
ziemlich gut in Firefox integriert.
Und dann ist es weg und dann kann ich mich trauen,
den Tab zuzumachen.
Dann kann ich irgendwann tatsächlich mal,
wenn ich die Pocket
Tablet-App aufmache, dann sieht es
so ein bisschen magazinmäßig aus.
Dann habe ich da diese Blogposts, die ich alle
irgendwann mal lesen wollte, habe ich offen.
und ich lese den dann aber auch nie,
weil ich mir meistens einfach bloß die Vorlesenfunktionen
mache und dann kriege ich diesen Artikel einfach von so einer
Roboterstimme vorgelesen
und auf die Art und Weise kann ich dann auch Blogposts,
wenn sie jetzt nicht zu viel Quelltext enthalten,
mir auch unterwegs
mal vorlesen lassen, während ich irgendwie
Fahrrad fahre oder sowas. Also das funktioniert für mich eigentlich
ziemlich gut, dann kriegst du dann doch
diese Längelächer rein und schmeiße ich auch manchmal so
einen Spiegelartikel rein oder sowas.
Oder das geht
für Deutsch und Englisch alles gut.
An diesen Service narrow.co.
Ja, genau, das ist was ich meinte, wo du irgendwie dir
einen Podcast aus deinen eigenen Bookmarks erstellen kannst.
Genau das meinte ich.
Wenn es fertig ist mit dem einen Artikel, liest du sofort den nächsten
Artikel vor. Ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Das geht halt nicht so gut, wenn Code drin ist,
was bei ziemlich vielen Artikeln, die auf meiner Liste landen,
der Fall ist. Aber für die anderen geht das sehr gut.
Da würde ich mir noch eine Optimierung wünschen,
dass er dann irgendwie, keine Ahnung,
was zum Beispiel bei der App noch fehlt, ist, dass du
in der App, wenn du auf Play drückst,
dann hast du nur noch das Play-Interface.
Dann kannst du nicht währenddessen den Artikel lesen.
Da würde ich mir dann wünschen, dass ich dann nebenbei
wirklich einfach den Artikel aufmachen könnte und sagen könnte,
ah, guck mal, hier kommt gerade Code, den gucke ich mir einfach
so mal an beim Fahrradfahren.
Vielleicht könnte man das wirklich optimieren, dass das Ding halt
zumindest Embedded GitHub sehr, sehr, sehr eindeutig
erkennt und wenn
Embedded GitHub Snippet kommt, das gar nicht versucht
vorzulesen, aber das halt dann wirklich anzeigt
und die Stimme sagt, hier ist gerade Code
und dann kannst du halt wirklich in den Player
schauen, wo du das gerade angezeigt hast.
Ja, das ist noch so eine
Spezialität, das fehlt noch, genau.
Ich habe gerade Lust, meinen eigenen Pinboard-Client zu machen,
das so ein bisschen schick aufbereitet. Vielleicht gehe ich das mal an.
Ich meine, man müsste relativ gut
parsen können, dass da jetzt wirklich ein
Codeblock kommt, weil da gibt es ja tatsächlich einen Tag für.
Das wäre eigentlich, das müsste
fast, warum machen die das nicht schon?
Das ist viel zu einfach eigentlich.
Gut, wollen wir da mal
langsam zu den Picks übergehen? Ja, ich glaube, wir
haben jetzt lange noch gelabert.
Was kannst du denn... Was hast du denn
für den Findings rausgesucht?
Also ich...
Also wir haben ja jetzt schon ein paar Sachen in die Liste
geschrieben, so an Kulturtipps und wo man
hinspenden kann und Videos
und J-Map und sowas.
Ich hatte
was Lustiges gefunden, was irgendwie momentan
oder zumindest vor drei, vier Wochen, als
ich dieses Pad hier aufgemacht habe, gerade so
rumging.
Wir hatten ja über
wie hieß dieses
Fisch-Aquarium im Sandspiel,
was wir letztes Mal
gemacht haben.
Wir hatten das letzte Mal über Orb-Farm geredet,
was so ein
sandspielartiger Aquarium-Simulator
ist. Und was ich da in der letzten Folge
schon bemerkt habe, ist, dass ich das lustig finde, dass
die die UI mit
98 oder ich glaube sogar mit
95 CSS gemacht haben.
Und das ist quasi CSS, was deine
UI aussehen lässt wie Windows 98.
Und kurz nach der Sendung
kam dann wieder das nächste raus, weil das gerade irgendwie
inzusammenscheinend ist. Es gibt Latex
CSS.
Das fand ich echt schick.
Da kannst du dann die Schriftart, ich wollte eigentlich mal nachgucken, wie diese Schriftart heißt, aber du kannst ja wirklich deine Webseite aussehen lassen wie so ein Standard-Latech-Dokument.
Sehr schick.
Also ich habe jetzt einfach mal an die Liste geschmissen.
Es gibt Latech-CSS, 98-CSS, 95-CSS und XP-CSS.
Und wenn ihr, liebe Zuhörer und Hörerinnen, noch andere Beispiele für solche CSS-Themes, für irgendwelche Sachen kennt, dann sagt da mal bitte Bescheid.
Super cool.
Genau, ich habe ein Projekt rausgesucht, das heißt PDF Archiver. Das ist eine Mac-App in erster Linie, die gibt es auch als iOS-App, die ist aber nicht ganz so relevant. Und zwar, was ich schon sehr gerne, schon sehr lange mache, ist versuchen jegliche Korrespondenz, die ich bekomme, also jegliche postalische Papierkrebs, der mit dem Papierkrebs kommt, den einzuscannen, indem ich einfach ein Foto von mache mit passender Software, die das optimiert gleich und das als PDF bei mir auf der Platte abzulegen.
und das ist sehr angenehm,
vor allem, wenn ein bisschen OCR da mit
drüber liegt.
Das funktioniert super gut.
Was ist denn, wenn du was dann geschreddert hast und dann brauchst du es
plötzlich nochmal und dann kriegst du es
nicht mehr geöffnet, weil es
irgendwie falsch gescannt wurde oder sowas?
Also ich habe, also bisher habe ich
keine falschen Scans. Ich sehe, was
ich scanne und ich habe da eine Preview
von und ich weiß, dass das lesbar
ist und die Qualität ist
genauso gut wie mit einem Flachbord-Scanner,
Mittlerweile mit einer Handykamera.
Also das ist einwandfrei. Das OCR,
das war ein bisschen zu wünschen übrig, aber das ist ja
nur on top. Das ist ja
das Obfus-Geräte nicht mehr in den Inhalt.
Das ist ja auch bei vielen PDFs so, dass die einfach,
dass da irgendwie Text drin steht, der bei
einem mit dem aufgelenkt ist. Genau, das ist einfach mit in die PDF.
Genau, es ist embedded, aber ich sehe trotzdem
den ursprünglichen grafischen Inhalt
nach wie vor in der PDF. Und ich habe mir
vor einer Weile mal ein Projekt benutzt,
das hieß Paperless. Das war so ein Hosted
Django-Dings, wo du das alles
drüber gemanagt hast. Das fand ich aber nicht ganz so geil.
Und habe seitdem das alles bei mir direkt auf der Platte gelegt,
einfach nur in ein paar Ordner.
Und habe die einfach über den iCloud synchronisieren lassen,
weil ich da gut vom Handy aus draufkomme.
Das ist quasi ähnlich wie die Dropbox.
Da hast du einen Ordner, der wird synchronisiert.
Bloß das halt über Apple synchronisiert wird.
Und da muss ich Dropbox-Ekel-Software nicht nutzen,
weil iCloud eh schon da ist.
Und ich kann auch zusätzlich noch ein paar Sachen nutzen,
wie Finder-Tags, um die Dinge zu taggen.
Und PDF-Archiver ist ein Liebhaber-Projekt,
was genau in diese Richtung geht.
Und quasi genau das macht, was ich schon länger immer gesucht habe als App, dass du einfach eine App hast, die überwacht ein Verzeichnis.
Und dann zeigt er dir die Dokumente aus diesem Verzeichnis an.
Kannst da einfach schnell mal durchscrollen.
Kannst dem Tags noch mit dran kleben.
Mit einer recht angenehm steuerbaren UI.
Und den Namen durch ein festgelegtes Schema gleich mit schieben.
Und dann legt er das in einen anderen Ordner und archiviert die einfach pro Jahr in einen Ordner.
Und das deckt sich genau mit dem, was ich bisher gemacht habe.
Der Namensformat ist noch ein bisschen härter, finde ich aber gut, weil dann ist es klar eindeutig.
Die Tags hängen am Namen mit dran und werden auch mit als Finder-Tags vergeben.
Somit kann ich überall danach suchen.
Ich kann das alles filtern und ich habe einfach alles sauber strukturiert.
Und so kann ich das Zeug, wenn es per Post kommt, ein Foto von machen mit der ScanBot-App, die ich benutze.
Landet automatisch in dem Directory davon.
Und wenn ich mal dazu komme, mache ich einfach auf Mac diese PDF-Archiver-App auf,
die auch Open Source ist, von einem coolen Entwickler gebastelt wird, der sogar schon auf dem Kongress war.
Das macht die App gleich noch mit viel sympathischer.
und der hat wohl die App, glaube ich,
vor drei oder vier Jahren auf dem Kongress auch mit den ersten
Prototypen entwickelt.
Müsste ich hoffentlich auf dem nächsten Kongress, wenn der stattfindet,
mal Hallo sagen, weil ich finde das Projekt
sehr toll, macht genau das, was ich möchte
und macht es sehr, sehr angenehm.
Hier ist so ein Sponsor-Badge.
Hier ist so ein Sponsor-Badge, da steht
Receives 0.00
Euros a week.
Kannst du also noch... Traurig.
Ich habe die App gekauft,
aber vielleicht soll ich dafür auch wirklich mal...
Aber die gibt es nur für macOS.
oder wie? Genau, das ist
eine macOS und iOS App. Die iOS App ist
wie gesagt nicht so relevant. Mit der kannst du auch noch scannen.
Das mache ich aber nicht über die App,
sondern über ScanBot.
Aber
das ist toll. Ich finde das super.
Kannst du ja der Vollständigkeit halber noch
ScanBot verlinken.
Ist eine Idee.
Was ist lustig, finde ich hier
Convention für die Tags.
Capital letters, spaces and language
specific characters such as
E, Ö, Ü und
SZ will be removed for
to maximize the file system compatibility.
Ja.
Alte Probleme.
Ja, ich meine,
du hast es nicht drin, aber ich nutze
das Zeichen sowieso nicht in Dateinamen.
Genauso wie Leerzeichen.
Also, keine Ahnung, mir gefällt das einfach nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich,
gefällt nicht, ist eigentlich auch dumm.
Ich wüsste auch nicht, wann ich mal zuletzt
etwas einen deutschen Namen gegeben hätte.
Das ist irgendwie, passiert nicht mehr.
So, ich pledge direkt dir mal Geld auf.
Libera Pay, das finde ich toll.
Ihr hört das hier als erstes.
Okay, und jetzt sieht auch sofort jeder,
wie viel du dem pledged,
weil ich noch null auf dieser Liste hast.
Ach, scheiße.
Okay, großartig.
Ich mache mal eine kleine Contribution.
Das sind 25 Cent die Woche.
Vielleicht stocke ich das noch auf,
aber ich habe die App ja auch gekauft.
25 Cent die Woche ist gar nicht mehr so wenig.
Das sind 12 Euro im Jahr.
Ich habe hier einen Read.
Der ist von Ende Mai noch.
Den habe ich da schon in meine
zu-vor-Podcast-Liste
geschmissen. Und zwar eine
Brief History
ECMAScript 4.
Oh, der kann
keine Payments annehmen. Sorry.
Habe ich deine
Aufmerksamkeit wieder? Sorry, ich hätte
vielleicht deine Geschichte zu Ende
erzählen lassen. Also ich hab
hier auch was in meine Liste aufgenommen und zwar
als Pick, weil es
einfach ein lustiger
Read ist. ECMAScript 4, the missing version.
Also vielleicht ist dir das nicht aufgefallen, aber jemand,
der täglich mit JavaScript arbeitet, der weiß,
das alte JavaScript ist ECMAScript 3
und das neue JavaScript
ist mindestens ECMAScript 5.
Das erste wurde es eigentlich erst ab 6 interessant, weil da
gab's dann plötzlich Kunst
und Let. Aber bei 5 ist das
erste Mal seit Jahren
wieder was passiert.
ich glaube sogar seit fast zehn Jahren oder neun Jahren zum ersten Mal wieder was passiert.
Warum ist so lange bei JavaScript in der Entwicklung nichts passiert?
Und dieser Post, ECMAScript 4, beleuchtet das so ein bisschen.
Es wurde nämlich jahrelang von diesem Standardisierungsgremium an ECMAScript 4 gearbeitet.
Und ich habe das in einem Studium mal als Projekt gemacht.
Da haben wir mal eine Flash-Anwendung gebaut.
Das war ActionScript.
Ein ActionScript ist faktisch ECMAScript 4.
Und ECMAScript 4 ist kein Subset von ECMAScript 5, denn dieser Standardisierungsprozess wurde abgebrochen und es ist nie wirklich released worden. Du erkannst es dir allerdings als Action-Skript ist es gelaufen. Und wenn du jetzt hier ein bisschen durchscrollst, dann siehst du da schon viele Sachen, die irgendwann auch in modernem JavaScript gelandet sind, aber auch Sachen, die zum Beispiel nie in JavaScript gelandet sind, zum Beispiel Typ-Annotationen an Funktionen oder allgemein Typing.
Du hast halt schon ein let-keyword und du kannst sagen, etwas ist entweder Variable A ist eine Zahl oder ein String mit derselben Syntax, wie du es in TypeScript hast. Das ist eigentlich ein lustiger Blast from the past, the JavaScript that could have been, ohne Transpilation, das allerdings leider nie in irgendeinem Browser gelandet ist.
Interessant. Es gab auch schon Big-Ins
und es gab
lustigerweise Packages.
Das lasse ich dann sehr Java-mäßig.
Es gab auch bereits Module mit
Import-Syntax. Das war halt genau das,
wie es in Action-Skript
auch war.
Und allein diese
Syntax-Beispiele sich durchzurollen. Es gab übrigens
auch
E4X ist
ECMAScript vor XML.
Es war quasi auch, hier ist quasi schon
JSX ist ja auch schon mit drin.
krass
genau und das hat einfach so viel
vorweggenommen und ist danach abgebrochen
worden und es nie
hat sich nie durchgesetzt und ist eigentlich witzig
weil da hätten wir sehr viele Sachen die wir heute durch
Transpilation kriegen einfach direkt
in JavaScript gehabt
hm
wäre ein interessanter alternativer
Zeitstrang auf jeden Fall
und jetzt gibt es einfach Version 4
nicht
das so als ein Pick von mir
schaut euch mal an
Aber es muss ja überall mal so sein.
Alle haben so Versionsprobleme.
Ob jetzt PHP oder
Pearl. Nee, Pearl hat nichts.
PHP.
Es gab irgendwie, gab es nicht
Pearl 6, aber dafür kein
Pearl 5. Ach nee, keine Ahnung.
Das war doch das PHP-Ding.
Es gab auch noch irgendwas anderes.
Bei PHP gab es 5 und 7. Da gab es glaube ich kein
PHP 6, genau.
Und Java hat sich irgendwann gesagt, wir lassen jetzt die
Major-Version weg, weil es irgendwie
Java 1.5
Anderswo einfach Java 5 und 1.6 hieß
Java 6 und irgendwann haben sie gesagt,
wir lassen jetzt dieses 1.5 vorne weg.
Viele behaupten, bei Swift
ist es immer genau andersrum.
Swift inkrementiert seit Jahren die Major-Version,
aber man soll es interpretieren als meiner Version.
So im Sinne von Swift 5
ist eigentlich Swift 0.5.
Ach so, weil es noch nicht mal fertig ist.
Naja, aber das sind, na gut, okay, das könnte man sich fast
vorstellen, weil es immer so Breaking Changes sind.
Auch mitunter, das sind ja schon
ganz schöne Umbrüche und Verwerfungen, die da in Swift
stattfinden. Sie haben ja seit ein paar
Jahren den Grundsatz, keine Source-Brushing-Changes
mehr zu machen. Haben sie ja auch nicht. Aber
die Bracken-Changes sind dann alle einfach nur in den
SDKs und du kannst dann Swift updaten und dann
werden Dinge im SDK plötzlich anders behandelt und plötzlich
hast du die genauso viele Brüchen-Changes.
Ich weiß noch nicht, ob das so eine clevere Idee war,
dass sie jetzt plötzlich ABI-
Stability eingebaut haben.
Ich meine, das ist sinnvoll, weil viele
irgendwie, es gibt halt sehr viel nicht freien
Aber die C++-Community leidet darunter,
dass sie sich nicht trauen,
ihre ABI-Kompatibilität zu brechen.
Weil es viele Projekte gibt,
die einfach Libraries aufbauen,
die sie nicht mehr selber kompilieren können.
Ich bin mal gespannt, inwiefern das wirklich zu Problemen führt.
Also aktuell ist der Vorteil halt gewesen,
dass Apple Swift shippen kann im Betriebssystem
und jede App nicht mehr die Runtime selber bundeln muss.
Aber das wird sicherlich irgendwann zu Problemen führen.
Über was wird denn das eigentlich aktualisiert?
Im Betriebssystem gibt es da irgendwie ein Package?
Über Betriebssystem-Updates.
Ach so, das ist dann, okay.
Die SDK-Versionen werden dann quasi mit dem OS direkt zusammen ausgerollt.
Ja, dadurch, dass du eine stabile ABI hast, ist das halt relativ egal.
Und bleiben die alten Versionen da liegen
oder funktionieren dann einfach gewisse Apps nicht mehr,
wenn ich mein Betriebssystem update?
Na, du hast halt eine stabile ABI. Das ist doch egal.
Du hast gerade gesagt, die SDKs brechen.
Ach so, ja, hängt davon ab,
gegen welche SDKs du baust.
Ach so.
Du kannst, also,
du hast die Backward-Kompatibility
eigentlich immer gegeben
und du kannst dabei jetzt,
also, du hast kein Problem,
eine alte App auf einem neuen Betriebssystem zu bauen,
aber du kannst jetzt nicht eine,
also auf einem neuen Betriebssystem betreiben,
aber du kannst jetzt nicht auf eine App,
die für iOS 13 gebaut wurde,
auf einem iPhone 5,
nee, keine Ahnung,
da läuft das wahrscheinlich sogar auch noch drauf,
nee, nicht mehr.
Also was darf jetzt älter sein,
die App oder das Betriebssystem?
Die App darf älter sein.
Ich habe eine App im Store,
die ist mit Swift 1.1 gebaut.
Die habe ich seitdem nicht mehr angefasst.
Das war auch ein Wunder, dass die überhaupt von Apple durchs Review gelassen wurde.
Weil damals gab es noch die schöne Regel,
wortwörtlich stand da so,
wenn du die App gebaut hast,
damit sie deiner Mom gefällt,
dann solltest du vielleicht nochmal darüber nachdenken,
ob die wirklich einen Mehrwert für die Allgemeinheit hat.
Du hast extra für deine Mom gebaut oder was?
Das nicht, aber die App macht halt nichts.
Die App heißt Cryptomate
oder Cryptomate, je nachdem wie du möchtest.
Und die kann halt Cäsar und Visionär Verschlüsselung
von Strings. Also du kannst da mit
ROT13 machen, wenn du möchtest.
Und die ist halt richtig hässlich und richtig
langweilig und macht halt nichts.
Und die ist halt in Swift 1.1 geschrieben, das erste Swift,
mit dem man Epson in den Store pushen konnte.
Es sind bestimmt irgendwo
in Nordkorea
Deserteure
verhaftet und hingerichtet worden,
weil sie sich auf deine Verschlüsselung verlassen haben.
Ja, meine Verschlüsselung ist es nicht.
Die hat Cäsar ins Leben gerufen.
Beziehungsweise Visionär. Aber das ist
wenn sie zweimal ROT13 benutzen, um Texte zu
verschlüsseln, ist das halt doof.
Doppel-ROT13 hält besser als Doppelverschlüsselung.
Wie heißt das?
Voll-Bit-Verschlüsselung vom Krypto-Chef.
Ja, es ist wie Test 3 oder
Triple Test, da hast du
Triple ROT13.
Aber Triple ROT13
ist doch wieder voll safe, da müsst ihr wieder...
Ja, da hast du genau das gleiche wie bei ROT13.
Double ROT13 ist halt dämlich.
Ja,
also
voll safe, ja, ja.
Oder du wählst eine Zufallszahl aus, dann ist das nicht zwangsläufig 13.
Oh ja, genau, nimmst für jeden Buchstaben einfach eine andere Zufallszahl.
Ja.
Der ist doch voll gut.
Sowas hatte ich in der Schule mal gebaut.
Da habe ich einen Verschlüsselungsalgorithmus,
als ich mich noch nicht damit auseinandergesetzt habe,
vor dem Abi hatte ich auch mal was gebaut.
Das hat quasi dein Passwort als Seed genommen
und hat jedes Zeichen dann fortlaufend
mit einer anderen Verschiebung verschlüsselt.
Das hat auch super funktioniert. Ich habe irgendwie den Bug nicht
rausbekommen, dass es beim Entschlüsseln irgendwie nach
50 Zeichen irgendwie falsch
entschlüsselt hat.
Aber gut, okay, ich habe es dann irgendwann aufgegeben.
Das habe ich auch mal, glaube ich, auf Twitter gelesen
von wegen, eine gute Verschlüsselung ist echt easy
zu bauen, aber das halt auch
wieder entschlüsseln zu können, ist halt der Twiggy-Teil.
Ja, aber dann ist es keine Verschlüsselung, sondern
einfach bloß Verschlüsselung. Ja, eben, es ist mehr Datenschreddern.
Nee, ist ja auch Quatsch. Eine gute Verschlüsselung
ist nicht einfach zu bauen, also eine wirklich
gute Verschlüsselung, aber ich fand es eine witzige Aussage.
Oh, ich hatte noch
einen Tipp, habe ich den jetzt irgendwie hier aufgelistet,
ich schreibe den mal noch nachträglich in die Show Notes
und zwar, gute Verschlüsselung
ist schwer zu bauen, selbst die Leute, die gute Verschlüsselung,
die jeder benutzt, bauen, machen es
falsch, zum Beispiel
OpenSSL.
OpenSSL wird überall verwendet
und man
rät allgemein davon ab,
was anderes zu, oder was
Eigenes zu bauen, weil
Kryptosche selber bauen ist halt immer Kacke, aber
es weiß halt auch jeder, dass OpenSSL-Kacke
implementiert ist.
Heartbeat war ein
kleines Beispiel davon. Es gibt lauter Sachen, die
in OpenSSL scheiße sind.
Ist ja auch ein unglaublich komplexes
Projekt. Genau, und dann gab's
halt Forks von OpenSSL.
Einer davon war Boring
SSL, das war, glaube ich, der von Google.
Und dann gab's Leute, die das nochmal vereinfacht haben
und runtergebrochen haben
und in Rust neu gebaut haben.
Das Projekt hieß Ring.
Wie heißt das? Ring.
Das ist nicht mal mehr Boring, das ist nur noch Ring.
Ach so, das ist einfach Boring minus Verwuchstaben.
Genau, also es gibt das Create Ring und das sind Fast Small Crypto.
Das ist einfach sehr viele Kryptostandards in Rust gebaut.
Manche sind auch, es gibt doch auch ein Verfahren,
mit dem du Krypto-Algorithmen einfach,
wo du einfach Code generieren kannst.
Aber das ist ein Projekt, das heißt, genau, Ring.
Und darauf basiert, also Rings sind wirklich bloß Krypto-Primitiven, also verschiedene Schlüsselverfahren, verschiedene Verschlüsselungs-Primitiven. Das ist jetzt keine Suite wie OpenSSL, mit der du jetzt auch wirklich eine Anwendung wie ein Webserver oder sowas bauen könntest. Das ist jetzt, glaube ich, kein TLS3-Handshake-Verfahren drin oder sowas.
Zumindest ist es nicht vollständig.
Darauf basiert aber Russells.
Russells ist, jetzt suche ich das nochmal raus,
das ist quasi Rust-TLS.
Und das ist jetzt von einer Pentesting-Bude mal reviewt worden.
Und das Review ist neulich ein bisschen durch Hacker News gegangen.
Das schmeiße ich mal, das habe ich gerade nicht parat,
aber das schmeiße ich mal in die Show Notes.
Und das fand ich eigentlich ziemlich cool,
weil das ist jetzt was, wo du sagen kannst,
ach, guck mal hier,
das können wir mal
irgendwie so dem Management oder den Kollegen
zeigen, man kann also, man muss nicht unbedingt
man muss nicht unbedingt mehr OpenSSL
verwenden, man kann auch
Services bauen, die
SSL oder TLS oder TLS
1.3 auf einer anderen Implementierung
basierend machen, eigentlich ganz schick
was noch dazu kommt, ist, dass OpenSSL
als Binary, glaube ich, ziemlich groß
ist und da sind halt sehr viele Sachen drin
die auch eigentlich deprecated sind
und die man eigentlich eh nicht mehr verwenden soll, die allerdings
noch aus Kompatibilitätsgründen mitgeschleppt werden
oder so. Ja, ich habe das Gefühl,
OpenSSL falsch verwenden ist fast noch einfacher
als Kryptoausfüßeln selber rollen.
Ja, genau.
Besser keine Krypto als falsche Krypto.
Nein.
Nein, nein. Das weiß ich auch.
Genau, ich brauche schon Krypto.
Nee, cool.
Ja, ich glaube, wir haben
genug, oder?
Ich denke auch.
Ich hätte noch einen Kulturtipp.
bestimmt auch genug von uns.
Genau, ich habe noch einen Podcast-Tipp. Vielleicht, je nachdem,
wie das mit dem Schneiden hier funktioniert, ist das bereits
runterladbar zu dem Zeitpunkt,
wo diese Folge jetzt hier zu Ende ist.
Und zwar, du bist
morgen in einem Podcast.
Das ist kein Podcast,
das ist so ein Livestream-Dings.
Also morgen ist ja Apples WWDC-Auftakt.
Das ist jetzt die Woche.
Und da bin ich
zu hören bei devtalks.
Also devtalks.de.
Link packe ich auch in die Show Notes.
Und zwar quatschen wir da einfach live
zum Keynote-Stream.
Also restreamen quasi die Keynote
und haben dann Gesichter drumherum als YouTube-Livestream
oder Twitch-Livestream oder irgendwo anders noch.
Und da kann man, also wenn man die Keynote
mit ein paar Kommentaren gleich mithören möchte,
kann man das darüber machen.
Nicht schlecht.
Ja, und ich bin, glaube ich,
morgen beim Pentacast oder
Penta-Radio. Ich bin, glaube ich,
morgen beim Pentacast zu Besuch.
Mal schauen, wie das läuft.
bin gespannt
ich freue mich auf die Folge
ja
das wäre dann quasi mein
mein fünfjähriges
das letzte Mal war ich vor fünf Jahren im PentaCast
oder PentaRadio
das wäre mein fünfjähriges Jubiläum
genau und das Thema verrate ich jetzt noch nicht
aber vielleicht könnt ihr es euch denken
okay
dann das war akronymisierbar Folge
die Antwort
Und der nächste Podcast, vielleicht auch die Folge 42 von irgendeinem Podcast, kommt in 3, 2, 1.